nous avons entrepris une mission unique
peut être la première de ce type dans
l'histoire de la marine russe
cette histoire est étroitement liée à la
culture
c'est l'histoire d'une communauté
nollywood est un groupe de personnes qui
veulent vraiment raconter leur histoire
c'est comme sortir avec un homme marié
oui c'est comme de sortir avec un homme
marié tu dois le faire vite et pas cher
si tu le fais vite
cela signifie que ce n'est pas cher si
tu veux faire des affaires ou pas et
coupez coupez
fact et les chaussants homme qu'est ce
qui vous a décidé à quitter votre emploi
à plein temps pour devenir blogueurs et
agriculteurs c'était dur bien sûr mais
nous l'avons fait et aux lettres
[Musique]
salut c'est pas aujourd'hui nous allons
répondre à vos questions sur été
frustrant ne savez pas par où commencer
je ne sais pas vraiment comment ça va
marcher
quel cauchemar je sais que c'était
d'idéalistes temps mais il n'y avait pas
d'autres possibilités fonction louis
gillet a été la chasse mon chéri
juste en laisse diffuser sa vie sur
internet est effrayant c'est terrifiant
même wise le papa tu vas me faire
pleurer aussi plus frustrante holtz on a
dû travailler dur mais notre rêve est
devenu réalité
c'est comme une télé réalité et très la
vie
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue suis raté
france pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités en plateau nos
reporters sur le terrain voici les
grands titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi
30 janvier edouard philippe a bon espoir
d'un compromis et l'issue de la
conférence de financement lancée
aujourd'hui à paris est perturbé pas
plusieurs dizaines d'opposants à la
réforme des retraites avant même
l'expiration des délais plus de 18000
amendements sur le projet de réforme ont
été déposées aujourd'hui en vue de
l'examen du texte en commission un
record sous cette législature
le royaume uni est la veille du break
site une sortie de l'union européenne
après trois années et demie d'un
feuilleton mouvementé
londres s'est fixé jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour renégocier les conditions
son départ alors que certains
promettaient un désastre économie
britannique se porte nettement mieux
prévu comment expliquer cette embellie
peut-elle durer dans le temps c'est ce
que nous verrons avec notre économiste
jacques sapir le corona virus a déjà tué
au moins 170 personnes en chine certains
états ferment leurs frontières avec le
pays et les compagnies aériennes
commencent à suspendre leurs vols vers
la chine en france un sixième cas
étaient confirmés ce soir l'idée d'une
possible épidémie dans l'hexagone a été
écartée mais l'inquiétude grandit tout
de même la ferme il a à l'adolescente
avait critiqué l'islam sur les réseaux
sociaux l'anc est ouverte à son encontre
pour provocation à la haine a été classé
l enquête pour retrouver les auteurs des
menaces de mort dont la jeune fille fait
l'objet celui quant à elle son cours que
révèle cette affaire précisément sur la
laïcité en france pourquoi une telle
polémique sur le blasphème est elle née
ce sera l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir
[Musique]
12 milliards d'euros par an d'ici 2027
c'est l'objet de la conférence de
financement du système des retraites
voulue par laurent berger et la cfdt
elle s'est ouverte tout à l'heure on
conseil économique et social et
environnemental réunis autour du
gouvernement les partenaires sociaux qui
doivent se mettre d'accord d'ici avril
pour équilibrer le régime des retraites
et à l'extérieur plusieurs dizaines
d'opposants à la réforme manifestent
leur mécontentement écouter certains
entre micro de guillaume à rossi et
dounia sied pour le nôtre quand sociale
pour les travailleurs les travailleuses
et la jeunesse elle débouchera sur rien
de toute façon la clé pour nous pour une
vie meilleure un présent un avenir
meilleur c'est l'issue de ce conflit
c'est l'issue de cette grève et donc du
supposé type de ceux des rêves c'est le
retrait ni amendable ni négociable c'est
pourquoi on pense aujourd'hui une partie
de l'intersyndicale qui a choisi qu'a
accepté d'y participer elle a rien à y
faire et on aurait des 5 décembre tous
les jours pendant ne sera dit qu'une
semaine macron il rigolerait un petit
peu différemment et probablement qu'il
aurait même eu le temps d'aller au
théâtre ceux qui croient en ce projet là
la cfdt l'unsa qui va nous expliquer que
finalement il ya des avancées possibles
qui sont prêts à négocier sur la réforme
des retraites actuelles lorsque le
financement total conseil d'état il
vient dire que cette retraite
c'est ce projet de loi ne tient pas la
route et que sainte un travail d'amateur
commence à ceux qui viennent encore
négocier ce ce set cette réforme ce
n'est pas possible c'est inconcevable ou
alors ça veut dire qu'on a à faire aussi
à des syndicats amateur est la sortie de
cette réunion le premier ministre
edouard philippe s'est exprimée s'est
montré confiant face à la collaboration
entre le gouvernement et les partenaires
sociaux et annoncé une prochaine réunion
pour le 10 février
elle nous avons indiqué que nous étions
prêts évidemment à entendre prendre en
compte les analyses financières qui
serait proposé soit par les
organisations syndicales soit par les
organisations patronales
je veux encore une fois salué le sens
des responsabilités des partenaires
sociaux et dire que j'ai confiance dans
la capacité que nous avons
collectivement en travail en nous
écoutant en évoluant peut-être chacun à
partir des positions qui sont d'une
autre à
trouver un compromis et donc à arriver
au terme d'une conférence sur
l'équilibré sur de financement qui est
un des moments importants de cette
réforme
j'ai par ailleurs indiqué aux
partenaires sociaux comme je m'y étais
engagé au mois de janvier qu'une réunion
multilatérale serait organisée à
matignon dans la semaine du 10 février
qui permettra de faire un point d'étape
est peut-être deux conclure sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui sont
travaillés en ce moment par le
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
dans le domaine de la pénibilité des
départs progressifs à la retraite dans
le domaine du travail sur les
transitions des systèmes actuels vers le
système universel et sur la question des
minimum contributif c'est à dire sur la
question des petites retraites garanties
à l'ensemble des actifs sur ces points
la discussion est intense elle se
poursuit alors il ya encore quelques
réunions organisées dans les jours qui
viennent
il m'a semblé utile que dans la semaine
du 10 février nous puissions nous
retrouver pour faire le point le cas
échéant pour conclure de façon à ce que
à l'assemblée nationale dès la séance
publique les éléments éventuelle de
conclusion en tout cas les éléments
d'avancé puissent être pris en compte et
pour en parler nous sommes nous avec
anne marie guillemard sociologue
professeur émérite à l'université paris
descartes sorbonne expert en conseil
d'orientation des retraites bonsoir
madame merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france on vient de le voir
sacré défi 12 milliards à trouver en
trois mois edouard philippe qui a bon
espoir en un compromis à l'issue de
cette conférence vous partager son
optimisme au premier ministre non pas du
tout pas du tout je crois que ça va être
très difficile mais surtout moi je
m'interroge sur ce qu'est devenue cette
réforme qu est ce qui reste de la
réforme de 2010 est proposé par le
candidat macro et justement vous n'étiez
pas c'est important de le préciser vous
n'étiez pas farouchement opposée petit
plutôt d'accord avec cette réforme
je regardais point très positif que je
peux rappeler
les seuls mots voilà vous fera du bien à
la mémoire le projet je le redis c'était
une réforme systémique et non pas
paramétrique donc plus de mesures d'âge
c'était annoncé comme tel
le projet c'était de trouver de
reconstruire une assurance vieillesse du
21e siècle où les mots ou la mobilité
professionnelle les parcours
professionnels sont devenus très mobiles
ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui les salariés
qui liquident leur retraite ont au moins
trois régimes et demi et donc des règles
différentes etc et ça devient illisible
et très bientôt cinq régimes
donc on imagine qu'on ne peut pas
calculer sa autres or l'idée d'un form
deuxième point important et c'est c'est
que pour rendre transparent le calcul de
la retraite le simplifier et gérable par
les individus s'appelle et ça leur
permet de choisir le moment opportun
c'est à dire que l'idée c'était d'avoir
62 ans comme âge plancher pour liquider
sa retraite et à partir de là vous
choisissez donc c'est ce que la cfdt a
appelé la retraite à la carte
on part soit 62 ans qui on estime que l'
on a moins de retraite mois une pension
retraite à 62 que si on attend plus
longtemps puisque il ya une incitation à
prolonger l'activité
donc ça c'était les points positifs mais
moi je ne les vois plus parce qu'on est
devenu on est rentré à nouveau dans une
réforme paramétrique comme on en a eu
toute une série depuis 2003 à moins de
cette réforme quand même depuis 2003 et
tout paramétrique et que le chaos oui
elle est oui facebook et donc les
mesures d'âge se réinstalle comme comme
élément central de la négociation
et oui pourquoi faut-il faire des
économies alors que l'idée et c'est ce
que disent
et jean-paul delvoye pour une fois en
france on fait une réforme à coût
constant 14% du pime l'effort français
était selon le cor conseil d'orientation
des retraites 14% du pipe jusqu'en 2070
vers le même corps qui nous expliquait
aussi que n'explique pas les indices à
17 milliards de déficit non mais ça
c'est télé c'est parce que on souligne
ça alors on a beaucoup sonné serment il
faut voir ici potez justement mais on
essaye maintenant sûr c'est une commande
du gouvernement oui oui non mais je sais
qu'il ya des hypothèses derrière et s'il
ya un déficit c'est parce que l'état se
retire et veut se retirer et que l'état
réduit le nombre de fonctionnaires donc
ça fait des cotisants en moins donc
c'est tout lié à l'état et à ses projets
ce n'est pas le déficit atteint donc on
nous fait croire que c'était déficit ce
n'est pas le déficit et que l'état veut
changer son mode de financement des
retraites
soyez plus précises parce que c'est
intéressant justement quand on vous dit
l'état veut changer à changer de
stratégie puisque vous l'avez répéter ce
n'était pas du tout dans le programme d'
emmanuel macron au départ effectivement
il avait bien dit qu'il réformerait les
retraites le système universel à point
mais pas de question de mesures d'âge
selon vous donc il ya une stratégie qui
est venu par la suite
oui tu as raison c'est darmanin philippe
au moment de pâques à peu près qui ont
sorti cette histoire de mesures d'âge
avec donc une raison un peu caché vous
nous dites clairement mais je pense
financière parce que et là de plus en
plus le jeu des bleus
le déficit est devenu au score or que
précisément dans le projet de réforme et
j'ai entendu maintes reprises jean-paul
delvoye le dire pour une fois on fait à
coût constant
et puis tout d'un coup il ya des
déficits peut-être oui mais et ça a été
un rapport spécial mais qui est lu
unilatéralement par le gouvernement il
prend les cas c'est pas du tout ce que
dit le corps si on le lit ligne à ligne
si on regarde les hypothèses qui ont été
faites les hypothèses fait présenter
dans le corps je n'ai pas pris mes
papiers
il a mérité sa 2e ce que ces départs le
corps ne sont pas tellement dramatique
il ya très peu de choses sur certaines
hypothèses il n'y a rien du tout les 17
milliards c'est dans le cas où
effectivement l'état se retire supprime
beaucoup de postes de fonctionnaires etc
aujourd'hui vous avez bon espoir quand
même que cette mesure d'âge d' équilibre
nous dit-on soit retirée sous la
pression de la cfdt qui les ont bon
espoir
j'ai pas bons espoirs c'était un des
seuls manifestement il ya une reprise en
main et est une vision uniquement
comptable et j'en suis désolé non moi je
suis même presque en colère parce que je
trouvais que c'était un beau projet que
de que d'actualiser l'assurance
vieillesse ou 21e siècle avec ce qui se
fait en finlande ce qui se fait en sus
elle ce qui est déjà été fait c'est à
dire 1 h plancher et après la
possibilité pour les gens contenu la
situation il ya des gens qui sont en
mauvaise santé qui veulent partir le
plus tôt possible
il ya d'autres qui ont des enfants
encore la parentalité tardive s'est
répandue dont il ya d'autres qui ont des
responsabilités parentales encore
impliquante qui veulent continuer parce
qu'ils veulent pas être retraité tout de
suite donc les si vous voulez les
mesures d'âge elles sont injustes
d'abord parce que hein on ne gouverne
plus aujourd'hui l'air les populations
par des mesures d'âge car à un même âge
les gens sont dit
ferrand aujourd'hui va dépendre leur
parcours professionnel
ça dépend de leur situation familiale
donc ils sont différents à 50 ans un
homme peut être en parentalité tardive
un autre peut être avec des enfants déjà
installés c'est ils n'auront pas la même
stratégie pour prendre leur retraite
donc l'argument très rapidement puisque
c'est terminé il me dit on me manque je
pose la question l'argument de justice
sociale vantée par le gouvernement ça
aussi elle a été là ce n'est plus de la
justice et de l'injustice qui va
travailler plus longtemps si on met la
lâche pivot ce sont les ouvriers quand
comment ces jeunes toutes mesures d'âge
est injuste et elle elle frappe les
ouvriers c'était le cas dans la réforme
sarkozy de 2010 merci beaucoup madame
anne marie guillemard d'avoir été avec
nous avoir apporté votre analyse merci à
vous exclusion de cédric villani à paris
groupe parlementaire éroder la campagne
des municipales semblent être un moment
délicat décidément pour la république en
marche le point avec les la salle une
période difficile pour le parti des
manuels macron d'abord des municipales
pas si simple à gérer
sans surprise cédric villani candidat
dissident de la république en marche à
paris a été exclu du parti par le bureau
exécutif mercredi soir la république en
marche prend acte que cédric villani
n'est plus membre du parti suite à ses
propos sans ambiguïté et son envie de
maintenir sa candidature librement le
bureau en a tiré les conséquences tout
en regrettant la situation le mouvement
a tendu la main à cédric villani
jusqu'au bout et continuera à oeuvrer au
rassemblement de tous ses adhérents et
adhérentes mais il n'ya pas que la
capitale qui suscite des interrogations
à biarritz le ministre de l'agriculture
didier guillaume et le secrétaire d'état
au tourisme et au commerce extérieur
jean baptiste lemoyne tous deux prêts à
s'affronter ont été priés de se retirer
le ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics gérald darmanin c'est lui
clairement positionné à tour pas après
avoir beaucoup parlé avec l'équipe
municipale je mènerai la liste aux
élections municipales à tourcoing le
président emmanuel macron m'a autorisé à
être en campagne électorale
si je suis tête de liste c'est pour être
mère une façon de laisser entendre qu'il
pourrait quitter le gouvernement dans un
avenir proche
lui qui avait déjà été élu maire de
tourcoing en 2014 sous l'étiquette ump
changer de bord quitter le navire des
initiatives qui ne sont pas rares au
sein de l air eau m le parti compte
actuellement 300 de membres et
apparentés à l'assemblée nationale alors
qu'ils étaient 313 en 2017
de tout temps les groupes politiques ont
connu des défections ou des frondes
comme ceux hollande ou même de gaulle
mais l'usagé était de rester dans le
parti la différence c'est que lrm n'a
pas la solidité nécessaire pour garder
ses députés et non pas eu le temps de
s'attacher au mouvement né en 2016 le
lien est plus superficielle donc plus
facile à rompre emmanuel macron qui
s'est tenu publiquement à distance des
municipales ne commande pas encore ces
départs reste à savoir si la motivation
et la cohésion au sein du parti
présidentiel sont toujours aussi fortes
et pour décrypter l'actualité dont sort
avec 9o johnny borgo conseiller udi de
paris en sciences et htc notre invité
politique
ce soir on va corriger ça tout
bonsoir x pozzo di borgo merci d'être
alerté france on a parlé des retraites
voilà juste une petite réaction de votre
part edouard philippe qui se montre
extrêmement optimiste un bon espoir de
trouver un compromis avec les
partenaires sociaux à l'issue de cette
conférence de financement vous vous
partagez
bon je sais pas si âmes en d'éléments
pour partager mais j'ai été évident que
la réforme des retraites devait avoir
lieu j'espère qu'elle aura lieu mais
c'est vrai qu'actuellement pas beaucoup
de confusion enfin moi je vois ça comme
observateur et j'espère qu'on trouvera
des solutions alors tant mieux si ce que
dit le premier produit ni série qui dit
souvent il a besoin de se rassurer dû
rassurer les français
j'espère que ce qu'il dit est vrai on
verra bien mais il ya quand même le
débat au parlement on a une
interrogation du sénat qui se disait
kika même est un peu interrogatif sur le
fait que 14 % de pib on n'a pas de
simulation financière actuellement le
débat aussi à l'assemblée je crois qu'il
ya quand même aux côtés à amateurs dans
cette gestion des choses voilà justement
de ces élus qui dénoncent on a vu alors
les républicains d'un côté la gauche la
veille qui dénoncera le mans je suis
plus parlementaires dont je me permet
pas d'intervenir mais j'aurais tendance
à dire que franchement la façon dont le
parlement a été traité c'est pas correct
et j'ai vu qu'il y avait des
parlementaires notamment l ère des faits
des républicains quand réagi et je pense
qu'ils sont tout à fait raison on a
ironisé rita probable répartition des
pouvoirs s'est réglé entre l'exécutif et
le parlement le parlement est normal la
vème république le parlement n'est pas
un grand parlement puisque la logique
majoritaire fait que le parlement est
souvent autour des effectifs mais là je
crois que depuis ce depuis deux ans le
parlement est vraiment vraiment mal
traités carrément on se rendre compte
que c'est vraiment une chambre
d'enregistrement il n'y a pas une action
ç'a toujours été un peu salace et game
republic
et n'oubliez pas que la 5ème république
ce pouvoir très fort du président et le
parlement qui est un fait accompagne
l'action du président mais là
manifestement on se rend compte très
bien compte que c'est vrai on a
l'impression que le parlement n'est pas
un acteur du jeu alors il ya quand même
mandement à leurs filets avant
l'expiration et l'examen du texte alors
ça ne va pas forcément empêcher le
monsieur de la loi mais est-ce qu'il est
souhaitable que le gouvernement passe en
force sur cette réforme quand on voit
les sondages quand on voit voilà la
fronde parlementaire c'est souhaitable
pour le gouvernant non moi je crois les
séances de monde à cette affaire c'est
un vieux débat quand j'étais
parlementaire on en parlait en il faut
faire cette réforme sarkozy elle avait
commencé il était passé à 62 ans il
avait commencé à toucher cette réforme
nécessaire des retraites
moi je te laisse à penser qu en plus
avec le système proposé au départ par le
président macro c'était quelque chose
qui est quand même touche l'ensemble de
la delà de la société et c'est vrai que
l'idéal aurait été de faire un
référendum c'est important alors leur
ferment pas lieu mais moi je crois que
là le parlement en face et si ankara 9 3
aussi déjà on voit très bien que ce dans
le texte lui-même je crois qu'il ya
presque 30 35 ans dans ce futur c'est
quand même si vous voulez où il avoue
d'ailleurs le conseil d'état le dit il
n'y a pas de cohérence dans 7 39
ordonnance et je crois que là c'est
quand même quelque chose qui n'est pas
très démocratique tel que je joue à
tellement lent chez pas aujourd'hui ça a
évolué mais c'est quand même un problème
on a vu la semaine voilà compliqué pour
l'exécutif notamment le départ et de
plusieurs élus
la république en marche 18
en déchantent sur le plan de la
république est en marche
par rapport à l'été un renouveau et me
côté vous savez comme vous des
parlementaires moi j'étais parlementaire
avait été concédée raidissement
maire-adjoint fait j'avais fait beaucoup
de travail parlementaire
là ça a été des parlementaires
choisissent sur internet
évidemment ils arrivent ils découvrent
un monde qui n'est pas le leur est tout
à fait normal si vous voulez que c'est
une crise au sein de ce parlement petit
à petit prennent conscience si vous
voulez qu'ils sont un peu d'aidé que des
relais d'une action qui ne maîtrisent
pas et beaucoup se réagissent
je trouve d'ailleurs quand et du fait
qu'ils avaient choisi pratiquement tôt
la parlementaire sur sur internet je
trouve qu'il n'est que 18 sont partis
c'est toujours déjà je ne sais pas
extraordinaire mais excusez moi mais
c'est un peu logique quand on crée pas
un parti politique on crée pas parlement
en tapant sur internet à tout ça ça est
ridicule
après la bulle et comarch qui aborde les
municipales comme vous le faites
d'ailleurs vous êtes soutien de rachida
dati on en parlera un petit mot tout
d'abord sur cette circulaire castaner on
part en compte les villes en dessous de
9000 habitants pour masquer une
éventuelle défaite quelle est votre
opinion là dessus mais c'est tout le
rôle de tous les midis l'intérieur je me
souviens de fer en 82 il savait qu'il
allait être battu
que les socialistes est battue ou
cantonal avait fait la même chose et il
avait enlevé les étiquettes de beaucoup
de conseils généraux de les mettre à
l'époque j'étais udf rpr
il a émis divers droite et divers gauche
est plutôt divers-gauche tailleur je me
souviens ça fait il ya vu une réaction
je crois c'est le monde qu avait réagi
et de fer a fait marche arrière mais je
veux dire c'est ac1 réfection d'un cycle
d'hamid l'intérieur qui est d'abord mise
à terre du pays mais qui est aussi le
chef de son parti et qui veut essayer
d'atténuer nu défaite possible ou en
résultat qui peut apparaître comme une
défaite
ces municipales alors là la division à
paris entre cédric villani benjamin
griveaux cédric villani donc exclure de
la république en marche
c'est une bonne chose quel est votre
notre vision un petit peu ce pour sur ce
couple il aurait dû partir cédric
villani se retirer complètement dont
j'ai pas moi poser de vrais la seule
chose que je regrette c'est que c'est
vrai que
fait paris alors c'est vrai que le prise
d'un maquereau a cassé l'ensemble des
parties à la façon dont il a
pratiquement éliminé le ps la façon qui
l'affaiblît l'ump qui même temps les lr
c'est quand même quelque chose c'était
un choc politique c'était une révolution
j'ai tendance à penser qu'avec tout ce
qui se passe à l'heure actuelle
peut-être qu'on va retrouver un clivage
gauche droite c'est pas évident c'est à
dire avec hidalgo et et rachida dati
mais je ne sais pas mais bon ça ce prêt
on va vers ça après ça ce qui concerne
la république à marchal me fais penser
vous savez quand j'étais j'ai commencé
très jeune ya longtemps parce qu'on s'en
souvient c'était quand elle est là la
guerre entre à l'époque michel d'ornano
qui était à l'époque le futur ubf il
faisait quand même 30 % dans les
sondages
et puis jacques chirac à l'époque de
être parce que simple et lumière était à
et si vous voulez or cette guerre a été
terrible mais qu'est ce qu'on a vu en
fait on s'est rendu compte si vous
voulez que bien que finalement petit à
petit ce sont les électeurs qui décident
et les électeurs à l'époque avait choisi
chirac plutôt que dano qui était à 30%
qui est un peu la marge aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que moi je crois que ce qui
s'est passé c'est qu'un marché partis
gagnants je crois d'ailleurs je me suis
enfin je veux pas trahir le secret mais
un jour on est au conseil de paris et
puis da luz l'usiné je comprends pas
c'est vrai que son parti gagnant mais
peut-être son entrée de m'aider alors ça
secret cette remarque de
actuel de ce que vous venez nous
raconter ça vous donne de l'espoir
finalement pour votre candidate rachida
dati deuxième à 20% pour le moment elle
pourrait peut-être créer la surprise à
rachida bête mais moi je pense depuis
déjà longtemps je suis avec à la mairie
septième depuis deux mandats de
mandature je pense que c'est
sérieusement je connais bien tout le
monde j'ai dit je conseille de 20 depuis
longtemps je connais bientôt je connais
moins bien les gens d'un marche qui
arrive mais je crois que c'est la seule
qui a le sens du populaire à paris elle
sent le s100 les lecteurs elle sent les
gens en difficulté elle connaît ce
problème là et moi pourtant dans le
viième kate upton en quartier fermé
s'est pas un hasard si vous voulez
qu'ils aient cette montée pour le reste
ça va durer ou pas je ne sais pas mais
c'est par hasard parce qu'elle est
porteuse vraiment les porteuses de cette
humanité que le politique a devrait
avoir et elle est vraiment ce sens
populaire et moi je suis toujours
admiratif pourtant dans ce quartier du
7e arrondissement qui plutôt un quartier
puis les jours déterminer c'est toujours
voir quels sont les gens qui sont en
difficulté elle va vers eux elle va vers
eux d'ailleurs on l'a bien vu dans sa
campagne
c'est la seule qui va des hlm de la
ville de paris quand des madame hidalgo
se prévaut qu'elle a fait une politique
du logement
elle est allée voir les logements des
hlm mais voilà quel état sont les
logements des hlm
elle est allée il a dit regardez
regardez ce que c est ce que vous avez
fait voilà c'est ce côté positif que je
crois alors on va voir la campagne vous
savez c'est quelque chose c'est le jour
des élections on sait qu'ils aient gagné
ou qui a perdu vous y croyez vous à ce
côté traditionnellement ce n'est pas un
vote sanction envers le gouvernement les
municipales mais cette fois ci ça
pourrait l'être oui alors c'est vrai que
manifestement les candidats marche que
ce soit monsieur griveaux même ville à
nice il puis en mars
ak même les conséquences d'un
gouvernement qui a fait du moins il d'un
président qui c'est vrai qu'il ya une
part de rejet dans une partie de la
population
on va le retrouver ça je crois on va le
retrouver dans l'électorat je ne pense
pas que l'élection soit essentiellement
ça mais il y aura une partie de ce
phénomène de rejet sur votre partie du
lectorat un pas tout ce qu'ils rejettent
le président peut se retrouver dans les
dents les voit que les candidats marche
comme un secret il faut espérer
parce que n'oubliez pas il ya un jeu pas
ya cinq six mois il était pratiquement
après les européennes il est élu maire
de paris il avait déjà choisi son ses
collaborateurs ses élus l'avaient déjà
fait sa politique a fait de cet effet et
qu'en cas d'élection elle se fait le
jour du vote
absolument merci beaucoup yves pozzo di
borgo d'avoir été avec nous en direct
restez avec nous ce sera l'édito ico de
jacques sapir qui nous parlera des
conséquences potentielles du bric site
et puis nous parlerons justement des
britanniques qui s'apprête donc à faire
ce grand saut avec un retrait effectif
demain
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si cet interdit d'interdire
tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il lui
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
en effet l'afghanistan n'est pas un lieu
tranquille ce n'est pas un bon pays
l'afghanistan est un endroit très
dangereux pour quelqu'un de célèbre
[Musique]
abbas est devenu célèbre
avant même de réussir ses amis sur
facebook
ses camarades de classe même des gens
dans la rue et des parents disaient
qu'il ressemblait à bruce lee chaque
fois que quelqu'un m'appelle bruce si je
suis aux anges
abbas ali se présente comme bruce lee il
imite les actes des infidèles l'islam
dénonce des actes contre la religion
commis par les musulmans marc machin
il doit simplement continuer à
s'entraîner ou peu importe sa religion
qu'ils soient musulmans ou non
voilà quelqu'un qui ressemble à bruce
lee qui peut réussir à garder sa mémoire
vivante
cela fera revenir la figure de bruce lee
dans le cinéma et le sport c'est génial
pour la promotion du sport
[Musique]
doss ier ici on connaît ses traditions
et ses festivités depuis le plus jeune
âge si tu es né à toute époque tu as de
la poudre dans le sang on n'a pas le
blâmer
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une petite brûlure mais ce n'est
rien
[Musique]
je ne dirais pas que nous sommes fous
nous sommes juste mexicain nous sommes
nés dans ce pays
[Musique]
c'est notre façon de vivre
quand on tombe amoureux on a des
papillons dans le ventre
ici à tout le québec on dit qu'on a des
feux d'artifice
[Musique]
merci nous rejoindre en direct sur rt
françois y est elle est bienvenue après
trois ans et demi d'un feuilleton riche
en rebondissements le royaume uni fait
enfin sombre exceed ce vendredi londres
se donne jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour
renégocier ses relations avec l'union
européenne bien des choses ont été dites
à ce sujet les dix plaies d'egypte
devait s'abattre sur l'économie
britannique pourtant rien de cela ne
s'est produit en tout cas pour l'instant
plutôt le contraire mais pour combien de
temps on voit ça tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir bonsoir aka
soyez le bienvenu alors j'ai fini
doit-on être pessimiste ou optimiste à
propos d'ubs rexie que réserve-t-il aux
britanniques
alors oui effectivement les adversaires
du bric site avait commencé à parler de
toute une série de cataclysmes et de
catastrophes qui allait se produire
et il l'avait fait de manière assez
consciente pour d'une certaine manière
terroriser les lecteurs britanniques ce
qui était d'ailleurs très mal le
connaître et ce qu'on a pu appeler le
projet peur n'a pas du tout fonctionné
alors il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui fin
janvier il ya de cela une dizaine de
jours en réalité le fonds monétaire
international a publié des prévisions de
croissance et comme par hasard on voit
que la croissance de la grande bretagne
est prévu pour les deux prochaines
années à un niveau supérieur de la
croissance de l'union européenne
donc voilà il va falloir effectivement
maintenant être un petit peu plus
sérieux et regarder quels sont les
atouts mais aussi peut-être les
faiblesses de l'économie britannique
alors jacques avant d'aller plus loin je
vous propose de voir ce qu'en pensent
les français que nous avons a rencontré
de ce break site qui se fait enfin leur
fait-il peur ou au contraire est-ce que
ça les intéresse
écoutez ils l'ont voté donc à partir du
moment où c'est ce qu'ils ont décidé
autant que ça se fasse le plus vite
possible
c'est dommage on les aura pu avec nous
tant pis pour eux mais c'est dommage
c'est une sortie au forceps en fait
l'europe c'est
se construit lentement difficilement des
x et bats perdre un membre s'est jamais
avantageux je pense qu'ils auraient
aussi eu le temps de refaire un
référendum pendant ces trois ans parce
que je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas du
tout une décision qui fait l'unanimité
là bas j'attends de voir
parce que à chaque fois ça a été reculée
reculer recul et donc j'attends là
peut-être la surprise de dernière minute
je pense que ça se fera pas tout de
suite à la non pas parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de sujets à régler certains
disent que ça peut être avantageux ya
pas mal d'entreprises camps sont en
train de réfléchir à s'installer ici par
exemple - mais ma boîte qui américaine à
la grosse partie est en angleterre est
de plus en plus c'est finalement les
embauches maintenant se font à paris
donc pour nous mon petit domaine
ces victimes wallace a l'air pas mal
fermé les frontières ça c'est quoi c'est
revenir en arrière
on a bien vu qu'il y avait des bienfaits
rouvrir les frontières à faire des pâtes
commerciaux internationaux etc
tu vois pas ce qu'on peut gagner je
pense que l'angleterre étant un grand
pays
ils vont pas s'effondrer aussi
facilement que ça avec le commonwealth
est derrière eux je pense que s'en
sortiront très bien bon on sait jamais
enfin je veux dire s'il ya des bons
accords avec l'europe si ils ont des
gros accord avec les américains
ils peuvent très bien s'en sortir voire
pourquoi pas mieux que l'europe
votre réaction jacques alors on entend
des choses qui sont très diverses mais
qui peuvent se résumer en d'abord oui
les gens sont non pas inquiet mais bon
ils ont conscience que ça va être un
petit peu compliqué bien sûr il ya aussi
des gens qui d'une certaine manière font
confiance dans le royaume uni qui voit
là c'est une grande économie n'est pas
trop la question du corps et noël mais
c'est vrai c'est une grande économie et
elle a de la ressource il a tout à fait
les capacités de résister aux chocs du
brésil et puis il ya ceux qui
visiblement continue de penser qu'il y
aurait une majorité de britanniques y
seraient opposés au président alors que
l'on sait maintenant que c'est très
exactement l inverse comme a pu le
montrer
l'élection générale qui a eu lieu au
mois de décembre alors c'est avec ce
break site
est-ce qu'il a déjà provoqué les
catastrophes
on nous avait prédit en ce qui concerne
la production britannique le pib vous
savez on en avait déjà parlé de lors de
l'émission sur le protectionnisme
et bien quand on regarde les courbes on
voit que le pib de la grande bretagne
il augmente à peu près au même rythme
que le pib de l'allemagne même là à un
petit peu plus vite que le pib de
l'allemagne
nettement plus vite que le pib de la
france je le redis ce sont les dernières
prévisions du fonds monétaire
international qui donne une croissance
de 1,4 pour cent pour la grande bretagne
mais plutôt de 1,2 pour cent pour
l'union européenne est un petit peu
moins par exemple pour l'allemagne donc
non ce qui est prévu pour les prochaines
années
c'est que l'économie britannique va
continuer de croître et de croître plus
vite que l'union européenne alors on
parle beaucoup jacques de l'impact
évidemment du bric site sur le chômage
est ce que ce dernier va augmenter ou
diminuer selon vous alors effectivement
le chômage avait d'ailleurs été un des
grands arguments pour le break 6
ce que l'on constate c'est qu'en fait
depuis 2010 le chômage en
grande-bretagne baisse à peu près au
même rythme qu'à baisser le chômage en
allemagne où il ya une très grande
différence avec la courbe de l'italie où
la courbe de la france alors ce qu'il
faut dire maintenant en perspective
c'est que le bric site va évidemment
réduire l'entrée des travailleurs
européens en grande bretagne donc ça
veut dire que les entreprises
britanniques vont devoir embaucher des
britanniques
ça c'est un bon point pour l'emploi
deuxièmement comme les salaires ont été
fortement augmenté le salaire minimum a
été augmenté de 6,6 pour cent au début
de cette année donc on a une situation
qui est plutôt favorable aux ouvriers
britanniques
le problème d'ailleurs c'est qu'elle est
peut-être tellement favorables
qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui s'inquiètent le
plus du bric si ce sont certaines
entreprises en particulier les
entreprises de main d'oeuvre alors jacky
bios des salaires est beaucoup moins de
chômage dit aussi inflation n'est ce pas
un risque au royaume uni pour la
compétitivité de son économie
alors vous avez tout à fait raison parce
que ça si vous voulez c'est un cocktail
quand vous avez
très peu de chômage quand vous avez des
salaires ils commencent à augmenter
fortement
eh bien on aboutir ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon d'économiste
je suis désolé je suis économiste et
c'est ce qu'on appelle justement
l'inflation qui est poussé par les coups
ou corse poche alors il faut d'abord
savoir que le taux d'inflation
il était déjà assez différent mais
depuis 2009 2010
vous voyez là il ya eu par exemple en
2013 et 2014
une hausse de l'inflation nettement
au-dessus du taux d'inflation qui était
celui de l'allemagne ou de l'angleterre
est par contre ce qui est intéressant
c'est que depuis le vote sur le
breitling donc le référendum de juin
eh bien l'inflation en grande-bretagne
est à peu près au même niveau que celles
en allemagne par contre elle est
nettement plus forte qu'en france
alors jacques je reviens à la charge ce
surcroît d'inflation surtout s'il devait
accentuer ces prochaines années ne
pourrait-il pas mettre l'économie
britannique en mauvaise posture quand
même effectivement c'est ce qu'on
appelle le problème de la contrainte
extérieure est là vous avez tout à fait
raison d'en parler quand on a une hausse
des coûts
si on a le même taux de change que ses
voisins on a un problème que la grande
bretagne a toujours refusé absolument de
faire partie de la zone euro elle a
toujours voulu conserver la livre
sterling est là ce qu'on voit c'est que
qu'est-ce qu'a provoquée le référendum
de juin 2016
magna provoquer une dépréciation de la
livre why et elle commence à baisser
avec les premiers sondages sur les
résultats du référendum et puis quand il
ya le référendum là elle tombe vraiment
et aujourd'hui on constate qu'il ya eu
une dépréciation d'environ 20 % du taux
de change
et cette dépréciation elle est plus que
suffisante pour couvrir les écarts de
coûts les écarts d'inflation entre les
pays de l'union européenne et la grande
bretagne donc d'une certaine manière
c'est le fait d'avoir conservé sa propre
monnaie qui la donnent à la grande
bretagne la flexibilité nécessaire pour
résister à un possible retour de
l'inflation
alors est-ce que ça a eu des
conséquences sur les importations et
exportations britanniques oui il ya une
petite conséquences et là encore si vous
voulez il faut bien regarder ce qui se
passe
jusqu'en 2013 à peu près bon il ya les
exportations et les importations font à
peu près au même niveau
après 2013 jusqu'à 2016 eh bien les
exportations sont moins 20 montrent
moins rapidement que les importations
donc le déficit commercial
évidemment augmente et puis à partir du
moment où on à la dépréciation de la
livre sterling qui donc survient dans la
deuxième moitié de 2016 et surtout
l'année 2010 elle est bien on voit que
les deux courbes commence à se resserrer
et on peut donc penser que d'ici les
prochaines années eh bien elles vont à
nouveau se recouper et qu'il n'y aura
plus de déficit commercial en grande
bretagne alors quelles sont les
perspectives de l'économie britannique
dans ce contexte du break 6 au niveau
des perspectives
d'abord il faut parler de
l'investissement on en avait déjà parlé
dans l'émission sur le protectionnisme
l'investissement n'a pas été affecté par
le vote de 2016 par contre les
incertitudes extrêmement importante
qu'il y avait eu en 2019 est temps qu'on
ne savait pas est ce que le break site
aurait lieu est-ce qu'il serait peut
être annulée et c'est bon ça ça a
déstabilisé les entreprises et là il ya
une chute des investissements en
particulier des investissements
étrangers en grande bretagne par contre
depuis que l'on est sûr que le break
site va avoir lieu à vannes depuis en
fait que boris johnson a gagné la
bataille des législatives en décembre
eh bien on voit un retour de confiance
important dans les entreprises donc ça
c'est un premier point
le deuxième point qu'il faut avoir à
l'esprit c'est le fait que la structure
des importations et des exportations
britanniques
elle est pas réellement centré sur
l'union européenne regardez c'est quand
même important alors ce sont des
chiffres qui datent de 2016 mais on en
voyait que déjà à cette époque là donc
avant le les effets du vote sur le break
6 et bien les exportations d un alecka
43% vers l'union européenne et que
le reste du monde c'était pratiquement
60% alors c'est moins important pour les
importations
et là il ya une raison très simple c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup d'importation en
grande bretagne qui sont ce qu'on
appelle des importations de proximité un
exemple classique c'est le bacon du
petit déjeuner anglais qui est acheté au
danemark est essentiellement bons mets
donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que évidemment la grande bretagne
commerce peut être plus avec le reste du
monde qu'avec l'union européenne et
c'est encore plus évident quand on
regarde la liste des principaux clients
de la grande bretagne
eh bien vous voyez les états unis font
19% alors que le total de l'allemagne et
de la france est quand même les deux
premières économies de l'union
européenne n'arrive pas à ce niveau là
et même si on ajoute l'italie troisième
économie de l'union européenne ben non
on ne va pas y arriver
donc ça veut dire effectivement que on a
une économie qui est plutôt tourné sur
le reste du monde que sur l'union
européenne et c'est pour ça que d'une
certaine manière le bric site fait sens
alors jacques selon vous pas de
catastrophe à l'horizon non pas de
catastrophe et tant pis pour tous ces
gens qui prédisaient le pire pour la
grande bretagne
non la grande-bretagne ne va pas
cannelle connaître de catastrophe avec
le break 6 merci jacques en tout cas de
votre analyse sur ses explications qui
font réfléchir merci à vous merci est
resté avec nous le break site ce sera
donc demain à 23 heures un moment choisi
par washington pour se rapprocher de
londres le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mike pompéo rencontre le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson
hier les députés européens eux ont
ratifié l'accord de retrait clément
hospital c'est le coeur lourd que les
eurodéputés ont fait leurs adieux aux 73
parlementaire britannique qui quitte le
parlement européen
vous nous manquerez mais nous aurons
toujours de l'amitié pour vous et vous
pourrez toujours compter sur nous comme
nous savons que nous pourrons compter
sur vous plus de trois ans et demi après
le référendum sur le bric site
le parlement britannique a voté hier
l'accord qui sait
le traité de divorce entre londres et
bruxelles un point de non retour pour le
chef de file du parti du bric site et
opposant historique à l'union européenne
nadj faraj le 31 janvier 2020 nous
quittons l'union européenne pour
franchir un point de non retour
c'est sa toute l'importance de cette
semaine qui est pour ce qui est de ce
que cela signifie pour nous sur le plan
constitutionnel de notre place dans le
monde
c'est probablement la chose la plus
importante depuis qu'henri lui qui nous
a fait sortir de l'église de rome
c'est pas là bas il n'y a pas de retour
en arrière possible dès le 31 janvier à
23h le royaume uni va rentrer dans une
période de transition qui durera jusqu'à
la fin de cette année pendant laquelle
ils continueront d'appliquer les règles
de l'union
un laps de temps prévu pour négocier la
future relation entre londres et
bruxelles qui ne sera pas sans
conséquence pour le négociateur en chef
européen michel barnier
il est très clair qu'il y aura des
conséquences négatives actifs
le ministre des finances s'agit de david
a reconnu la semaine dernière que
certains points de l'industrie seront
confrontés à des retombées négatives
taouil fait négative fallout quel que
soit l'accord que nous atteindrons sur
notre future relation le brésil sera
toujours une opération visant à limiter
les dégâts
le royaume uni a déjà passé plusieurs
années à négocier les termes de son
départ avec la commission européenne
mais les négociations vont rentrer dans
une nouvelle passe dès vendredi emmanuel
macron nice qu'ils aient les prémices et
le dialogue ne s'annonce pas facile à
établir le royaume uni s'il quitte
l'union européenne ne quitte pas
l'europe
ils y restent ancrées et tout lire
attache sa géographie son histoire son
identité mais il nous faut bâtir un
nouveau partenariat unique très étroit
en matière de défense de sécurité de
commerce et cette relation devra
renforcer l'union européenne et non
l'affaiblir
aujourd'hui sera la toute dernière étape
avant le grand départ
le conseil des états membres doit
adopter par écrit le traité de divo
ce qui mettra fin dès vendredi à 47 ans
d'une relation souvent houleuse entre
londres et bruxelles pour en parler on
retrouve en direct de londres notre
reporter ben hassen chébili bonsoir
bassem j -1 donc avant la date
officielle du bric cité des jalons qui
se prépare un 31 janvier de festivités
qui divise les onglets quelle est
l'atmosphère à londres et le programme
de demain
effectivement c'est effectivement ce
n'est pas lui c'est vraiment un
événement historique que s'apprête à
vivre londres un événement qui divise
les anglais entre les progrès xittel et
anti habré xix déjà depuis le début de
l'après midi sur le parvis de once
mister juste derrière moi les antilles
habré exit sont réunis et sont toujours
présents ici avec des drapeaux européen
et des drapeaux complètement e lumineux
ils sont bien décidés à rester ici et se
faire entendre pour rester dans l'union
européenne il parle notamment de
déchirures d'abandon et même d'être
orphelins ainsi la grande bretagne kit
union européenne et c'est bien ce qui va
se passer demain ils sont là depuis tout
à l'heure avec des slogans hostiles à
boris johnson johnson qui devrait
prendre la parole de demain pour cet
événement historique que les anglais
vont vivre des festivités qui devrait
commencer à partir de 21h30 avec un
écran géant qui devrait être disposés
ici big ben ne sonnera pas car beaven
étant en travaux mais de nombreuses des
équipements qui seront disposées ici
pour imiter les sons de cloche de big
band et prises de paroles des discours
des festivités beaucoup d'activités qui
seront organisées demain à partir de 21
heures 30 et ce jusqu'à 23 heures
certains députés très propres excite ont
même décidé d'organiser une soirée très
tard dans la nuit sur le thème de
l'angleterre avec un repas typiquement
anglais du vin typiquement anglais elle
a même déclaré qu'il n'y aura pas de vin
aux français pour souligner ce
nationaliste ont signé cette fierté
britannique et cette sortie de l'union
européenne boris johnson tant qu'à lui
va prendre la parole pour un discours à
la nation depuis le 10 downing street
et puis il y aura ce bien sûr cette
prise de parole et un cadre en alu
une qui sera acquis refus qui sera
projeté sur la façade du 10 downing
street pour représenter bien sûr big ben
qui pourra pas raisonner à demain et
pour représenter surtout les dix coups
de minuit avant cet événement historique
la sortie du royaume-uni a depuis le
bras existe mais ce n'est pas une sortie
que sera automatiquement fait à partir
de demain elle sera très longue à leurs
preuves apprendra à peu près onze mois
donc on ne parle d'un divan qui est acté
mais le cadre reste encore à définir
et puis bien sûr nous reviendrons demain
dans le courant de la journée sur ces
festivités que les britanniques
s'apprêtent à vivre
merci ben hassen chébili en direct de
londres et l'ecosse aussi quitte l'union
européenne craint triste jour pour sa
population qui s'était largement
prononcés contre le break sic arriver
demain et j'essaye de ne pas y penser
ces nouveaux 50 pence qu'ils vont mettre
en circulation
pour moi ce n'est pas une monnaie légale
quand je vois le bric site je vois les
états unis d'abord toutes ces politiques
sont vraiment préjudiciable aux efforts
que nous devons faire pour résoudre les
problèmes mondiaux
je pense donc c'est une chose très
négative je ne veux pas que cela se
produise
comme la plupart des écossais j'ai
l'impression que ma voix n'a pas été
entendu en tant que pays nous avons été
exclus
nous n'avons pas de voir west nile tard
donc non je ne veux pas que cela se
produise je préfère rester au sein de
l'union européenne
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec les nce forman
eurodéputés et membre du parti
conservateur c'est notre vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir lense forman merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors
tout d'abord petite question un peu
humoristique et provocatrice aujourd'hui
est ce que vous avez toujours un travail
toujours j'ai toujours un travail un
travail 80 corps auquel je suis toujours
employé en tant que député européen et
cela se terminera à minuit demain
hu à 23h au royaume uni les votre état
d'esprit ce soir extrêmement dangereux
bilan cela ne fait pas très longtemps
que je suis en politique j'ai commencé à
m'impliquer dans les politiques
européennes en 2019 la raison de mon
application c'est que le gouvernement se
trouvait dans l'ornière et n'arrive plus
à avancer en tant qu'homme d'affaires
avec un peu d'expérience ou tout en
rouge et je vais le sentiment que je
devais agir dans les limites du possible
pour faire avancer les choses car
l'indécision causé beaucoup de
souffrances colorado il fallait que nous
prenons position pour avancer et je suis
très heureux de dire que mon collègue et
moi ont réussi à résoudre cette
situation notre succès lors des
élections européennes a permis à
abhorrer jeune soeur de devenir un autre
dirigeant elle a réussi à obtenir un
accord avec l'union européenne et le
voici
c'est un moment historique pour leurs
amis et aussi pour l'europe et je pense
que dans les pages de l'histoire cela
sera un moment très positif alors un
homme son travail mais un homme heureux
est ce que vous êtes au confiant en tous
points pour l'avenir est ce que pas de
doute pour vous aucun l'âge d'or prédit
par boris johnson ça va être au spla
arrivé du jour un doigt oui bon ça mais
je pense certainement que nous serons
plus en plus indépendants nous courons à
conclure des accords commerciaux du
monde entier
je pense que relativement court terme
côté rebelle britannique a prospéré et
que le reste de l'europe à nice observée
très attentivement car c'est nous nous
en sortons bien et je pense que cela
sera le cas d'autres ce dur est peut
être regarder le royaume uni peut être
que nous devrions les îles iten n'ont
pas besoin d'être dans l'union
européenne
pour prospérer et je pense que l'union
va commencer à se détricoter ne pourront
alors avoir une nouvelle relation
oubliez le fédéralisme et les
dysfonctionnements de cette monnaie
unique qui ne peuvent pas fonctionner à
la fois pour l'allemagne et pour la
grèce donc le cap que prend union
européenne et créer des dangers du
ressentiment même à l'extrémisme l'union
européenne doit se réformer en
profondeur
et pourtant elle refuse que le président
sera peut-être le déclencheur d'une
nouvelle vague de coopération
aujourd'hui vous le dis pour vous vous
avez fait votre job
qu'est ce que vous attendez maintenant
de boris johnson puisque c'est à lui de
jouer il y aura une longue période d'un
an de négociations ça peut tomber à
droite comme à gauche on ne sait pas
trop ce qui va advenir qu'est ce que
vous vous souhaitez offrir jusqu'à la
fin de l'année pour négocier un accord
de deux commerces de libre échange et
j'espère que les deux parties seront
raisonnables et trouveront quelque chose
qui est dans l'intérêt de tous je pense
que cette année va être intéressante car
l'union européenne n'a pas encore tout à
fait réaliste compris le brésil et au
cours des mois à venir
il falloir qu'elle compose avec et dans
les mois qui suivront cela il faudra
qu'elle comprenne à quel s'accommode du
trou dans leur budget parce que le
royaume uni était le deuxième
contributeur le plus important du budget
ils ne vont pas vouloir réduire leurs
dépenses c'est qu'ils auront un manque à
gagner et ensuite ils vont même devoir
se demander si ils veulent punir le
royaume uni courage pour être parti ou
coopérer et d'ici la fin de l'année ils
comprendront qu'ils seraient dans leur
bonne intérêt d'avoir un bon accord de
libre échange
un bon accord pour le royaume uni comme
pour l'union européenne la président de
la commission pierre sud à van der leyen
était plutôt conciliante on ne sera
jamais bien loin
c'est de bon augure selon vous renault
ne sommes pas très loin de rester des
fois ça et nous voulons être de bons
voisins
nous avons juste une approche différente
ne souhaitions pas être contrôlée par le
cor centralisée de nuire au peigne fin
nous voulions un peu d'indépendance et
nous considérons comme une des économies
font de faire leur sélection
indépendante et qu'elle travaille pour
la propres intérêts dans le cadre d'une
démocratie libre et s'agissant notamment
de la technologie le rythme des
changements au 21ème siècle est très
différent du rythme du milieu du xxème
siècle à l'époque où l'union européenne
a été créée ces démocraties ne peuvent
pas suivre ce rythme donc je ne pense
pas que l'organisation de l'union
européenne permet un fonctionnement
correct
cela a très bien fonctionné pendant des
années mais
le monde a changé et l'union européenne
et l'europe aussi vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous êtes un businessman pour
vous on a plus intérêt aujourd'hui
clairement devenir des partenaires ou ou
des concurrents finalement une ride to
be bop nous devons être un peu des deux
je suis
il est prospère dans la concurrence la
concurrence engendre l'innovation elle
permet de rendre les produits et les
services aux enchères pour les
consommateurs ce qui est bon pour
l'économie et la croissance dont il doit
y avoir une concurrence la concurrence
c'est bien et c'est l'un des problèmes
de l'europe
elle a toujours essayé d'être
protectionniste et le protectionnisme
ralenti en fait l'économie et c'est
pourquoi l'économie de l'eurozone a été
l'une des économies à la croissance la
plus lente de la planète nous devons
être en concurrence nous devons innover
et nous devons être partenaires nous
sommes dans un deuxième économie
mondialisée il faut travailler de
concert et c'est très positif
merci beaucoup les sports majeurs au
député et membre du parti conservateur
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france restez avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons du corona
virgule du virus pardon et à l'instant
d'ailleurs l'om est-ce qu'ils décrètent
l'urgence nationale air france suspend
ses liaisons avec la chine jusqu'au 9
février la russie elle va fermer ses
frontières avec la chine
[Musique]
il y a une problématique de
documentation extrêmement importante de
la demande en eau depuis la révolution
verte qui a conduit à cette
autosuffisance alimentaire de l'inde
dans ces zones climatiques aride il ya
quasiment plus d'eau en surface
on compte maintenant à peu près sur le
pays de l'ordre de 25 millions depuis
pomper ce qui est six fois plus que la
chine
cette image une femme qui porte un pot à
eau sur la tête et une image que l'on
voit partout
pour les femmes c'est une charge énorme
des petites filles peuvent pas aller à
l'école parce qu'elles doivent aider à
cette tâche par exemple donc ça accentue
des inégalités 85% de l'eau consommée
en inde les par l'agriculture c'est un
des premiers exportateurs de blé de riz
des peas qui consomment énormément d'eau
pour être produite à l'échelle mondiale
d'eau virtuelle c'est à dire l'eau qui
est contenu dans les produits qui sont
échangées l'inde est un des plus gros
exportateurs d'eau donc c'est à dire que
c'est un paradoxe en soi
la crise de 2008 arrive et à ce moment
là on s'aperçoit que les choses ont été
mal faites
on n'avait aucunement prévu des
scénarios de clips de défaut de paiement
tant qu'on maintient la grèce avec les
mêmes conditions qui ont provoqué cette
crise
vous aurez le même système il serait
plus cohérent qu'elle reprenne son
existence en main monnaie comprise mais
je reprendre saab sa monnaie ne résout
pas tous les toutous les problèmes bien
sûr qu'il faut changer les hommes qui
dirigent parce que sinon vous ne
résoudrait rien en sortant de l'euro on
veut en fait forcé la marche du
transformation d'un pays donc
effectivement peut-être que certains
grecs ont envie de voir cette marche de
transformation du pays est sans aucun
doute une grande partie n'ont pas envie
de cette transformation son entrée dans
l'euro est en grande partie responsable
de ce qui lui arrive
semble plus important c'est la descente
dans le cas contraire les oursons ne
peuvent pas être relâchés dans la nature
combien de centimètres
ça doit être à peu près cet ennemi n'est
pas mort lors c'est parti et va
récupérer les eaux sont ces bons l'ours
a sauté s'est jeté sur moi elle m'a
manqué de quelques centimètres
[Musique]
à l'atterrissage quelque chose a cassé
le train d'atterrissage oui c'est
compliqué l'aérodrome et glacé les gars
ça commence à m'énerver
battus voile au regard notamment jeu pas
fait attention et quelle est la
profondeur si on tombe des 4000 m
liège store j'espère qu'ils pourront
obtenir des données uniques sur le champ
magnétique
mais ça c'est le toit du monde cela veut
dire que tout est possible
les gens ici m'ont fortement étonné un
échec collectif c'est une véritable
équipe dont les membres sont prêts à
travailler sans broncher colis d aide
pour à vue de nez que tout se passe
comme près
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoint pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce jeudi l' oms vient de décréter
d'urgence internationale face aux
nouveaux coronavirus qui a déjà tué au
moins 170 personnes en chine certains
états ferment leurs frontières avec le
pays et les compagnies aériennes
commencent à suspendre leurs vols vers
pékin en france un sixième cas a été
confirmé
la ferme hilare cette adolescente qui
avait critiqué l'islam sur les réseaux
sociaux l'anc est ouverte à son encontre
pour provocation à la haine a été
classée l'anc est en revanche pour
retrouver les auteurs des menaces de
mort dont elle fait l'objet
quant à elle suit son cours que révèle
cette affaire exactement sur notamment
les questions de laïcité en france
pourquoi une telle polémique sur le
blasphème est elle née peut-on encore
blasphémer dans notre pays ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
le nouveau coronavirus l' oms qui vient
de déclarer l'urgence nationale et pour
lutter contre sa propagation la russie
annonce son intention de fermer ces
quelques 4000 250 km de frontière avec
la chine pour revenir sur la situation
retrouve antoine claireaux notre
correspondant à moscou
la cellule de crise créée en début de
semaine par le premier ministre russe
michail michou style est désormais
opérationnel et plusieurs mesures ont
d'ores et déjà été adoptées ainsi à
compter du 31 janvier
certaines sections de la frontière entre
la chine et la russie seront fermées à
la circulation
autant pour les véhicules que pour les
piétons le trafic ferroviaire entre les
deux pays est également suspendu à
l'exception notable de la liaison moscou
pékin concernant les vols depuis et vers
la chine les contrôles ont été renforcés
dans les aéroports et les ministres
russes de l'intérieur et des transports
ont prévu de se revoir dans deux jours
afin de refaire un point
quant aux ressortissants russes encore
présents sur le sol chinois
la porte parole de la diplomatie russe a
dressé un tout dernier bilan
l'ambassade et les consulats généraux de
russie en chine suivent de près la
situation et sont en contact avec nos
compatriotes
il continue les travaux visant à
déterminer le nombre de citoyens russes
qui se trouvent dans les zones de
propagation de la maladie au 30 janvier
aucun cas d'infection pour ce
coronavirus n'a été signalé chez les
citoyens russes se trouvant sur le
territoire chinois
le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères fournit toute l'assistance
possible aux autorité exécutive fédérale
compétente dans leurs contacts avec les
autorités chinoises dans le cadre de
leurs réactions aux risques liés à la
propagation du coronavirus la russie et
compte plus de 4000 kilomètres de
frontière terrestre avec la chine
et c'est un report accueille chaque jour
des dizaines de vols en provenance de
villes chinoises
les autorités russes suivent donc de
très près l'évolution de la situation
sur place
et face à cette épidémie la commune
interne assure l'international se pose
la question de l'organisation du
rapatriement de leurs ressortissants
présents en chine de nombreux ministres
ont pris la parole aujourd'hui à ce
propos écouter
vous devez avoir vu notre demande
d'affréter deux avions en chine pour
ramener les ressortissants indiens qui
sont dans la province du hubei une
demande officielle a été faite nous
attendons maintenant l'approbation
officielle de la partie chinoise avant
de pouvoir entamer le processus et nous
espérons que cette approbation sera
bientôt donnée concernant le cas du
nouveau virus en chine
il n'est pas nécessaire d'interrompre
les vols en provenance de chine car cela
ne fera qu'affaiblir l'économie
cambodgienne et dégrader les relations
entre le cambodge et la chine
il n'est pas nécessaire d'évacuer les
étudiants cambodgiens
les ambassadeurs et les employés
consulaires d'autres régions de chine
vers le cambodge
aujourd'hui de son citoyen japonais
reviendrons de wuhan nous continuons de
travailler pour faire en sorte que
toutes les personnes restantes une
rentrer chez elle et continuerons de
faire tous les efforts pour gêner la
sentier des rapatriés en fin de compte
notre gouvernement fera ce qui est dans
le meilleur intérêt de l'australie et
des australiens
c'est ce que nous faisons ici nous avons
des australiens en détresse nous
proposons de les faire sortir de cette
partie de la chine et de les ramener
chez eux mais nous voulons nous assurer
qu'ils traversent la période d'isolement
et je pense que les mesures que nous
avons prises sont appropriés dans
l'intérêt de notre pays et les relations
internationales
dans ce contexte de corona à virus on en
parle avec claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales bonsoir
claude blanchemaison le coronavirus est
ce qu'on peut parler d'un test pour la
chine tout le monde évidemment va
scruter comment ce pays j'ai aimé et
puis évidemment tout le monde regarde
comment les dirigeants chinois traitent
la question et notamment en comparant
avec le traitement
en 2003 du strass et de ce point de vue
évidemment d'abord il faut dire que la
chine n'est plus la même chine 17 ans
plus tard c'est une chine tout à fait
différente qui s'est beaucoup développée
et puis dans le le patron et chez jean
ping qui il veut se montrer efficace
alors il a d'ailleurs dit ce qui est
très important il a déclaré que et il ne
fallait pas que les fonctionnaires
locaux fasse de la rétention
d'information pour défendre je ne sais
quel intérêt local et qu'il fallait que
l'information soit ouverte autrement dit
que tout le monde soit transparent par
ailleurs il a pris des décisions très
très très très rapide pour faire
construire des hôpitaux alors sont des
hôpitaux de campagne bien sûr pour
soigner les chinois qui sont infectés
par le virus ou qui pourraient l'être et
on voit qu'il a pris les choses en main
d'ailleurs le directeur général de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé qui
était à pékin il ya deux jours au début
de la semaine trois jours lui a donnés à
une sorte de satisfecit en disant que la
chine faisait tout ce qu'il fallait
faire pour endiguer cette épidémie
alors si la communauté internationale
estime que le gouvernement chinois n'en
a pas fait assez
est ce que par hasard la chine pourrait
être sanctionné sanctionné elle va
l'être nécessairement sur le plan
économique puisque toutes les opinions
publiques dans tous les pays du monde
demandent à leur gouvernement de prendre
des mesures quelles mesures prenez vous
pour protéger nos nationaux et par
conséquent cela veut dire que des
mesures sont prises par pratiquement
tous les gouvernements pour soit
rapatrié les nationaux soit coupé les
liaisons aériennes avec la chine est
évidemment ceci aura des conséquences
sur l'activité économique en chine
on dit même que probablement la chine
perdra un point de croissance
si cette épidémie eux durent quelques
mois comme c'est vraisemblable
elle revient de le voir et vous venez de
nous lire le directeur de l' oms qui
était en chine l'om est-ce qui a décidé
à l'instant de déclarer l'urgence
internationale ça aussi ça peut avoir
des conséquences claires sur sur la
chine
bien sûr alors j'allais dire enfin parce
que effectivement c'est ce que l'opinion
publique internationale demandait et on
a même on a même dit que la chine avait
tout fait pour freiner sa libération en
début de semaine
vrai ou faux peu importe en tout cas
maintenant c'est fait et en effet ceci a
des conséquences et crée des obligations
pour tous les pays dans lesquels le
l'épidémie que ce délai susceptible de
se développer
et effectivement je crois qu'il faut
dans une un cas de ce genre que la
coopération internationale joue son rôle
une coopération médicale une coopération
scientifique
les chinois ont transmis très tôt toutes
les données sur le virus et sur le
séquençage adn du virus alors ça n'avait
pas été le cas en 2003 pour le strass il
faut qu'une coopération internationale
et dans le fond il ne faut pas jouer un
petit jeu géopolitique d'un pays contre
un autre alors vous paraît effectivement
de la confiance qu'on peut avoir dans ce
pays
vous l'avez dit on peut lire plein de
choses partout est-ce qu'on peut
clairement faire confiance à la chine
certains articles de presse a un qu'on
ne citera pas disait voilà ils
sous-estiment les chiffres est ce que la
rend évidemment vous ne vous n'avez pas
là la vérité mais
est-ce qu'on peut être là dedans on peut
avoir confiance selon vous désormais
écoutées
j'ai l'impression que le gouvernement
chinois ne veut pas tomber sous cette
critique que la famille la ilaha illa il
a fait l'objet d'une critique très près
sévère en 2003 sur son traitement du
strass et je crois qu'il est attaché
en effet à la transparence des
informations en chine à la coopération
internationale et à la coopération
d'autres notamment à travers
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
mais bien sûr on n'empêchera pas les
flics news de circuler moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que quand on interroge les
médecins et on en voit beaucoup sur les
chaînes de radio et les chaînes de
télévision généralement ils ont plutôt
un ton rassurant
bien sûr c'est très sérieux il faut
prendre la chose au sérieux bien sûr il
faut isoler les individus qui sont
contaminés et puis il faut les traiter
mais dans le fond l'avis des médecins
c'est que ça n'est pas encore une grande
pandémie mondiale
alors il n'empêche ikea fermer tous ses
magasins en chine certains pays
rapatrient leurs ressortissants on l'a
vu air france suspend ses vols
est ce qu'il ya une sorte de mise à
l'écart est effectivement de la chine je
pense que il ya un effet d'entraînement
les pilotes d'air france on avait voté
une motion pour dire après tout british
airways iberia et et la lufthansa et et
leurs filiales supprime tous les vols
pourquoi est ce qu est la france ne le
fait pas donc air france c'est
finalement l'as fait elle a décidé cet
après midi je crois qu'il ya un effet
d'entraînement en effet est il
actuellement les grandes entreprises
sont aussi amenés à rappeler leur leurs
ressortissants à les faire revenir à la
maison
peut-être aussi pour se mettre à l'abri
d'éventuels recours
parce qu'après tout un employé français
pourraient se retourner contre son
entreprise et l'entreprise contre l'état
qui n'ont pas facilité le retour à la
maison
donc chacun joue du principe de
précaution
la russie elle qui ferment carrément ses
frontières avec la chine c'est une
nécessité là encore une obligation c'est
un pays voisin il ya une frontière en
effet comme on l'a dit dans votre
reportage de quatre mises 250 km c'est
considérable la mongolie a pris la même
mesure
et effectivement je faudra voir comment
concrètement cette mesure est appliquée
parce que les quatre élèves et quatre
mille 250 km ne sont pas surveillées
mètre par mètre
c'est totalement impossible donc dans
l'immédiat le ministère des affaires
étrangères de russie a dit qu'il ne
devrait pas y aller il n'y aurait plus
de délivrance de visas automatique ni à
la frontière pour les chinois qui se
présente puisque cette procédure était
possible ni à moscou et à
saint-pétersbourg pour les chinois qui
viendraient en visite professionnelle ou
ou touristiques
alors pour le reste le contrôle de la
frontière c'est probablement une autre
affaire merci beaucoup claude dame
blanche maison nous avoir apporté votre
analyse mercia beau et retour en images
maintenant sur les moments clés de cette
épidémie sur le territoire français pour
en parler nous sommes avec le docteur
général kir zec médecin urgentiste à
l'hôtel dieu ap hp
bonsoir gerald crise grecque merci
d'être avec nous en direct
bon sur rt france on l'a dit l'om est ce
qu'on vient de déclarer l'urgence
internationale
concrètement le médecin que vous êtes
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça change pas grand chose c'est l'
urgence de santé publique de portée
internationale la dernière fois que ça
va être déclenchée c'est en juillet 2019
à propos d'une épidémie d'ebola je mets
au défi quiconque de se rappeler de ce
déclenchement de cette urgence sanitaire
de santé publique
donc ça va pas changer grand chose et en
particulier concrètement pour nous sur
les recommandations sur la prise en
charge il va pas y avoir de portée
justement de prise en charge et de
mesures concrètes qui vont changer
moi j'ai un peu peur simplement que ça
rajoute un peu de l'huile sur le feu et
que ça rajoute un peu dans une hystérie
un peu collective on comprend pas bien
pourquoi depuis le début on a
l'impression grand manque la sauce est
en train de monter autour de ce
coronavirus alors sous réserve qu'on
nous donne les bons chiffres en chine
mais pour l'instant 171 morts en chine
sur un territoire de 1,5 milliard de
citoyens
on n'est pas sur quelque chose qui est
dramatique je rappellerai juste qu'en
france chaque année ces 10000 à 15000
morts de la grippe dans l'indifférence
générale
or le coronavirus ce sont des symptômes
d'une grippe peut-être d'une grippe
un peu plus méchante que les autres mais
en tout cas ça a les mêmes modes de
propagation et les mêmes symptômes de la
fièvre de la toux
donc cette urgence de santé publique
clairement elle va affoler h commencé à
regarder déjà sur les réseaux sociaux
les gens s'affolent parce qu'ils ne
comprennent pas bien les mots font peur
comme les mots de virus mystérieux
chinois faisait peur aussi et là on a
une combinaison qui est assez
d'étonnantes en termes de communication
tout simplement
justement il ya 2 6 4 et ont été
confirmés en france un 6e ce soir
mais risque ce que ça se propage comment
ces personnes sont elles prises en
charge
alors on n'est pas il faut sortir du
fantasme de plaies que vous savez la
transmission de la pesc de contagion le
film et brad pitt vous avez un patient
zéro qui va infesté toute la planète et
qui va tuer à chaque contact on est de
l'ordre avec le quoran à virus de
quelque chose qui est plus de l'ordre de
la grippe or la grippe chaque année il
ya deux millions cinq millions 8
millions pour l'effort d'année et
l'effort des épidémies mais en tout cas
la pandémie mondiale de grippe elle
existe donc là il est probable ex
coronavirus comme c'est un mode de
transmission par les gouttelettes 1 par
la respiration qui est similaire à celui
de la grippe qu'on ait une dissémination
sur la planète
après la vraie question c'est quelle est
la virulence quelle est la gravité de ce
virus est ce que ce virus c'est une
grippe
un peu compliqué et ça donne des
pneumonies mais globalement c'est pas
très grave et ça touche des gens qui
sont fragilisés et c'est dramatique pour
les gens qui sont fragilisés mais on
voit bien qu'il ya déjà des maladies qui
vont le premier patient qui est décédé
en chine par exemple avait déjà une
tuberculose plus une une infection du
myocarde donc on voit bien que ça a été
un peu la goutte d'eau qui a fait
déborder le vase mais le corona virus en
lui-même n'a pas été responsable de ce
décès donc soit c'est un virus qui est
pas plus virulent que ça il va falloir
redescendre d'un cran en termes de
communication parce que nous aux
urgences par exemple ou dans les
services hospitaliers ça va être
impossible de mettre tout le monde en
isolement soit il est très virulent et
ça voudrait dire que la chine peut être
nous cache un certain nombre de choses
ou que les chiffres ne sont pas les bons
chiffres et à ce moment là s'il est très
virulents ces accès au moindre contact
avec des gens qui n'ont pas
d'antécédents médicaux
il ya un risque et une gravité ça veut
dire que là effectivement on a raison de
prendre toutes les précautions mais ça
m'a posé problème parce qu'il faudra
voir le nombre de services de
réanimation qui permettront d'accueillir
les malades potentiels
rona virus se soignent fils
il se soigne pas asser qu'il passe tout
seul mais un peu comme la grippe quand
vous avez la grippe ou le coronavirus on
va vous donner du paracétamol pour faire
baisser la fièvre on va donner
éventuellement des antiviraux pour les
cas les plus graves
et puis surtout c'est surveillé
l'évolution donc là c'est quand vous
avez des symptômes toux fièvre des
symptômes respiratoires et que vous
revenez de chine
ce sont les critères de la région
concernée ou bien que vous avez en
contact avec quelqu'un qui est un cas
diagnostiqué ce qui est le cas du
sixième cas avec le médecin qui a été en
contact avec un patient qui lui même
avait des symptômes qui ont été
confirmés dans un deuxième temps eh bien
il faut mettre en isolement et puis il
faut surveiller l'évolution 12
l'hospitalisation systématique on isole
et on surveille la situation évolue bien
vous allez sortir de l'hôpital la
situation évolue mal vous allez aller en
réanimation mais on voit bien que c'est
gérable sur cinq sites à 60k mais dès
qu'on va dépasser une centaine de cas
par exemple en même temps ça va devenir
compliqué à paris à cette chambre à
l'hôpital bichat cette chambre à la
pitié salpêtrière d'isolement et puis
après on va vite être limité par les
moyens de ses chambres d'isolement c'est
la même chose sur les moyens de
réanimation donc c'est pour ça que je
souhaiterais vraiment que l'on puisse
peut-être redescendre la tension si on a
affaire à un virus qui n'est pas si
grave que ça on n'est pas sûrs et voilà
on n'est pas sur une maladie ou des cons
vous touche globalement vous allez avoir
des complications gravissime
alors évidemment il ya toujours les
petites questions pratiques qu'on
connaît tous mais c'est bon de les
répéter
quelles sont les précautions à prendre
c'est une précaution qu'on appelle les
barrières universelle qu'on devrait
prendre chaque année mais là encore plus
c'est que coronavirus c'est d'abord se
laver les mains prendre le réflexe de se
laver les mains régulièrement d'utiliser
des solutés hydro-alcooliques c'est ces
petits jeunes qui permettent quand on
n'a pas de point d'eau de se désinfecter
donc il faut le faire encore plus
souvent la deuxième chose c'est prendre
des bons réflexes ne pas aller tout
c'est par exemple et lé postillonner
dans l'herbe est plutôt utilisé sa
manche éveillé vous allez éternuer dans
votre manche par exemple utiliser des
mouchoirs jetables vaut éviter d'avoir
des réservoirs à microbes et des
réservoirs à virus
et puis la quatrième chose c'est quand
on est soi même malade c'est de porter
un masque mais là il faut complètement
arrêtée avec l'idée que le masque que
masque chirurgical le petit masque bleu
de chirurgiens et ça ne protège pas du
virus on voit plein de gens se balader
dans la rue avec ce masque là les
pharmacies sont dévalisés ça ne sert à
rien ça protège quand soi-même on est
malade pour éviter de contaminer les
autres mais le masque ne filtre pas
c'est les particules dans l'air et en
particulier les virus dont il faudra un
masque de plus haute protection qu'on a
à l'hôpital par exemple pour éviter
d'être contaminée et l'autre fantasmes
qu'il faut complètement arrêté c'est la
discrimination sur les populations
asiatiques
voyez la meilleure des preuves c'est que
parmi les cas qui sont hospitalisés
notamment le dernier c'est pas du tout
une personne asiatique donc il faut
arrêter avec ce bashing systématique de
dire attention je veux pas mettre à côté
d'un touriste chinois au jeu pas les
manger dans un restaurant chinois
ça n'a aucun sens puisque ce n'est pas
la communauté chinoise qui véhiculent ça
il trouve comme tous les virus de la
planète ils partent d'un endroit dans le
monde souvent c'est en asie pour des
raisons de saisonnalité tout simplement
et il se propage de toute façon sur la
planète
certains chercheurs on a lu peut-être
que c'est encore faux aveux ne le dirais
estime que cette épidémie devrait
connaître son pic d'ici une semaine ou
dix jours ça veut dire quoi est ce qu'on
est capable aujourd'hui de dire bah
combien de temps ça va durer
quelle importance ça va prendre
[Musique]
alors il ya des modèles mathématiques
qui permet effectivement de calculer
quand on sait qu'une personne va
contaminer par exemple trois ou quatre
personnes on est capable de faire la
cinétique de 2,7 de cette épidémie on
est capable aussi de voir sur la planète
comment elle se comment elles se
déplacent après les chercheurs estiment
le pic de l'épidémie mais c'est une
estimation ça peut se déplacer sapeurs-
flamber comme ça peut s'éteindre
d'ailleurs juste pour rassurer nos
téléspectateurs et téléspectatrices une
épidémie qui serait mortel le virus se
propage très très vite et qu'une
épidémie mortelle
vous mettez une ville sous cloche vous
voyez bien que vous aller éteindre
l'épidémie parce que malheureusement
vous allez avoir des milliers voire des
millions de morts on en est je pense pas
là parce que là on aurait les
informations donc on voit bien qu'on est
sur un modèle de diffusion qui est plus
un modèle traditionnel une forte
contagiosité mais une gravité qui est
une gravité pas si élevé que ça ou en
tout cas pas parce qu'on imaginait au
départ
donc c'est clair qu'il va falloir voir
la cinétique à la courbe avec le nombre
de cas qui va redescendre il peut y
avoir un rebond le voit très
classiquement que les épidémies de
grippe aussi mais en tout cas là le pic
n'est pas atteint ça c'est sûr et qui on
voit bien que les cas augmentent et
quand les cas augmentent un peu partout
sur la planète
ça veut dire que progressivement toutes
les zones s'allume et qu'on va arriver à
un stade de pandémie mais pandémie ne
veut pas dire mortalité élevée pandémie
ça veut tout simplement dire que le
monde entier il ya du virus qui circule
et ce en permanence on a des virus qui
circulent notamment le virus de la
grippe merci gerald ciolek en tout cas
pour ces propos rassurants qui met les
points sur les i merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt français je vous
le propose est tout à leur retour en
images sur les moments clés de cette
épidémie sur le territoire français ou
un sixième patients donc a été molle v
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
oh
avec à tous autorisés avec restriction
la 5g hawaï une manière pour londres et
bruxelles de ne pas trop se fâche et de
ne pas trop fâché washington et pékin
écoutez l'analyse de ya de mal leurs
spécialistes du numérique
l'idée étant de ne pas se couper du
marché américain mais ne pas non plus se
froisser avec le marché chinois qui est
aujourd'hui prépondérant
c'est une position d'équilibriste entre
bas certains arguments qui peuvent
s'entendre notamment sur la protection
et la sûreté de dd des sites les plus
sensibles notamment les sites militaires
et puis de l'autre côté on n'interdit
pas tout développement de web sur le
territoire européen ou anglais est ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'on
a la même que la même problématique la
même question est quasiment la même
réponse
alors que les anglais sont en train
d'être dans l'actualité également
alexander vinik vient d'être placé en
détention provisoire en france ce
ressortissant russe a été extradé de
grèce jeudi dernier il a décidé de faire
appel il est soupçonné d'escroquerie et
de blanchiment d'argent sur l'une des
principales plateformes des changes de
bitcoin alexander binic et mis en examen
pour extorsion en bande organisée la
russie réclame son extradition wigno
mongeon ligne est nous ne pouvons pas
accepter la position non constructive de
nos partenaires français qui ont été
omis de signaler à la partie russe en
temps opportun l'arrivée d'alexander
vinik en france et son transfert dans un
autre hôpital le 24 janvier je tiens à
dire que pendant plus de soixante douze
heures les agents du consulat russe se
sont vu refuser à plusieurs reprises et
sous divers prétextes la possibilité de
rencontrer le citoyen russe ce qui
constitue une violation flagrante des
dispositions de la convention de vienne
sur les relations consulaires signé le
24 avril 1963
les avocats constate des incohérences
dans son dossier ainsi que des
violations de la procédure comme neuve
par les autorités françaises
ni aprilia nous jugeons inacceptable
qu'une telle pression soit exercée sur
l'accusé et c'est ainsi que nous le
qualifions de la part des organes
judiciaires et de la police de la
république française si le forum sur la
paix se tient à paris où on donne la
possibilité à la société civile de
prendre la parole et d'exprimer son
point de vue face à la société civile et
où le thème principal des interventions
et les droits de l'homme
veuillez les respecter vis-à-vis d'une
personne en particulier il ne s'agit ni
d'un déséquilibré ni dans meurtriers
n'ont donc fait l'objet de menaces de
mort depuis et que révèle cette affaire
exactement soit la laïcité en france
pourquoi une telle polémique sur le
blasphème est elle née peut-on encore
blasphémé en france nous en débattrons
avec nos abonnés
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
feytiat coût politique a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui est
extrêmement serré
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
mais
on a construit
attention attention à la tête mais
qu'est ce qui fait que nous allons
découvrir le meilleur de kertch on a
construit ça doit être beau
attention watts or on a construit et le
bon tu le vois oui il est en
construction on la construit avec six
mois d'avancé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui pousse tout simplement un
apnéiste à vouloir touchées les abymes
le but ultime c'est pas forcément de
gagner des médailles le podium m6
d'arriver à gérer ses émotions dans un
certain environnement et c'est un
univers qui nous permet justement
d'aller encore plus loin dans cet état
d'introspection et de travail sur le
corps et aussi sur l'esprit plus on va
être dans l'instant présent plus on va
être capable de gérer ce qu'on en a à
faire est concentré sur ce que l'on fait
et a confiance et la capacité à vivre
l'instant présent à être connectés que
sur ce qui se passe sur les sons sur le
toucher sur le ressenti et ça nous
pousse dans les retranchements à changer
des choses dans notre propre vie en
dehors de l'apnée
les chefs-d'oeuvre de la peinture sont
comme des livres ouverts sur les siècles
passés les contempler ces découvrir le
regard que portent les artistes sur leur
époque
[Musique]
il est un thème qui a toujours eu une
place à part dans l'histoire de l'art
c'est celui de l'enfance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que le regard de l'artiste a changé
entre cet enfant iconique peint sous les
traits de jésus par jean fouquet et sept
enfants couverts de toute la tendresse
de sa mère peint par elisabeth vigée
lebrun
entre le regard triste de cette jeune
fille contraint de vendre ses charmes
dans les rues de londres et
l'insouciance de cet enfant à qui le
suisse félix vallotton donne la liberté
de ne même pas regardé le peintre
de l'allemand dürer aux flamands
revendiquent de l'espagnol velasquez au
moderne renoir miro et picasso à travers
toute l'europe du moyen âge au 20e
siècle les grands maîtres de la peinture
n'ont cessé de représenter les enfants
selon les canons de leur époque
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coût
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
28 ans 30 soyez les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france 1 c'est une enquête
classée sans suite le parquet de vienne
s'est prononcé aujourd'hui en cause la
procédure ouverte pour provocation à la
haine à l'encontre d'une jeune lyonnaise
le 18 janvier milhazes saison est pris à
partie sur instagram après avoir tenu
des propos insultants envers l'islam
l' enquête se poursuit contre les
menaces de mort et de viol émises à son
encontre la mini de la justice s'est
exprimée hier à ce sujet selon nicole
belloubet je cite on peut critiquer les
religions pas incité à la haine
la ministre a depuis admis une malade à
raison ces propos qui n'ont pas manqué
de faire réagir beaucoup
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer dans notre
pays pour qu'une ministre de la
république puisse dire que l'insultent à
l'encontre d'une religion est une
atteinte grave à la liberté de
conscience
on s'apprête à rétablir un très peu
laïque droit au blasphème belloubet
parle comme elle agit tout faux même les
religieux du concordat en alsace moselle
ont demandé l'abolition de la répression
du blasphème bigoterie et autoritarisme
marchent ensemble stupéfiants belloubet
veut interdire le blasphème dans notre
pays
c'est en finir avec la république milla
doit être défendue non poursuivies
belloubet peut-elle encore être ministre
de la république
la question se pose l'outrance et la
vulgarité de ces attaques en ont choqué
plus d'un
mais elle ne justifie en rien les
menaces qui la visent et déshonorent
ceux qui les profèrent milla à 16 ans
elle a toute la vie pour découvrir que
l'islam est peut-être autre chose que ce
qu'elle croit l affaire me la suis son
coût entre la polémique elle enquête
pour retrouver les auteurs du
harcèlement dans la jeune fille victime
que révèle cette affaire exactement sur
la laïcité en france pourquoi une telle
polémique sur le blasphème est elle née
est-ce qu'on peut toujours en blasphémé
en france c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre
kamada guina cofondateur du mouvement
des droits civiques bonsoir gamin nabina
merci d'être avec nous ses côtés nader
allouche journalistes bonsoir à vous
également donc une polémique avec cette
jeune femme qui a blasphémé entre
guillemets volontairement je le dis
alors que ce n'était pas un blasphème
pour là je cite vous comprenez déjà que
cette affaire ait créé la polémique et
malaby nasa vous a étonné le savez tenue
pour tout vous dire ce quiz sur cette
information à deux jours s'étaient
montés en épingle dans les réseaux
sociaux je m'attendais pouvant pas une
telle ampleur parce que bon quand même
dit gamine de 16 ans et quand j'ai vu
quand j'ai vu à quel niveau on est
arrivé de débat national sur une affaire
qui est au départ privé chaud ça
extraordinaire qu'est ce que ça dit
justement
selon vous que ça y est atteint ce
niveau de débat c'est que ça te dit
quelque chose oui clairement la france
est scindé en deux aujourd'hui il ya les
laïcs et les l'écart qui sont autant d
day et puis aller il ya les autres qui
sont croyants pas nécessairement
musulmans vous avez les juifs qui sont
extraits qui ont eu l'occasion de
discuter avec avec quelqu'un du
consistoire ces questions là les
intéresse vraiment parce qu'ils sont
inquiets vous le cache pas et puis les
catholiques évidemment et évidemment les
musulmans qui sont en première ligne
parce que c'est ce qui pose problème en
france aujourd'hui c'est vrai que là on
peut se poser des question de savoir
pourquoi on est scindé en deux nevers
hallouj
écoutez moi je crois que l affaire est
grave
nous parlons d'une jeune fille de 16 ans
qui se trouve aujourd'hui menacée
empêcher d'aller à l'école dans le pays
des droits de l'homme parce qu'elle a
dit ça me toute cette phrase tout à fait
anodine je crois l'islam c'est de la
merde
écoutez slam est une religion de haine
le coran c'est de la merde pardonnez moi
de citer cette phrase mais voilà c'est
ce qu'à la dui précisément j'aimerais
que nos concitoyens musulmans nous
prouve le contraire
la vérité c'est que vous attaquer fort
la latte pour avoir quelques problèmes
sam adams l'islam est la religion d'un
prophète qui dixit les sources
scripturaires de l'islam lui même était
un pédophile où il ya eu des relations
alors l'islam est là venant jouer on le
relève la thérapie la guyane l'islam est
la religion d'un prophète qui a eu des
relations sexuelles avec une fillette de
9 ans aicha cela se trouve dans la
biographie canonique de mohammad et
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
en irak madame il y a eu un projet de
loi pour abaisser l'âge légal du mariage
à 9 ans pour les filles et aujourd'hui
nous avons des organisations musulmanes
en france tels que ben youssef qui
invite des hommes comme monsieur al
qardaoui qui ne disent pas moins que
cela il est légal d'avoir des relations
sexuelles avec des fillette de 9 ans
alors moi je demande à nos concitoyens
musulmans qu'il nous prouve que d' islam
est une religion de valeur pour ça
encore faudrait-il qu'il encore
faudrait-il qu'ils réforment leurs
discours et peut-être aussi qu'ils
réforment leur historiographie bon
latéral gauche je vais je vais les
cérébraux de gamme à la vina
vous avez conscience effectivement ce
genre de propos peuvent extrêmement
choqués notamment les musulmans qui nous
regardent ça peut être potentiellement
assez explosif vous assumez vous vous
êtes dans une forme de provocation si
ces propos les chocs
alors il n'y a qu'une chose à faire
qu'ils quittent l'islam où l'orthodoxie
musulmane
colette pour des mouvements qu'elle
hétéronome vous avez des musulmans tout
à fait modéré qui sont catastrophés par
mais important interrogent leurs textes
ce n'est pas moi qui dis que ma maman
ramada a eu des relations sexuelles avec
une jeune fille de 9 ans
c'est écrit dans sa biographie canonique
alors que les mangas mal être alors
lorsqu'un aîné que je vais donner je
reconnais que je me suis dit lâche sur
ce cas nous dit que ça fait l'extrême
droite
là je suis choquée du propos parce que
c'est les gens d'extrême droite qui à
longueur de journée d'un réseaux sociaux
nous balance neuf ans neuf ans neuf ans
d'abord il a jamais heureuse aux
relations sexuelles avec une femme de 9
ans je rappelle que fabrique ses 17 ans
a dit voilà maintenant ce n'est pas le
coran hadith authentique
j'entends aussi qu'on en dise qu'ouvrir
la prédication islamique
il y a donc le coran qui le texte ont
révélé de dieu dans tout ça
et il y a ceux qu'on appelle les a dit
donc c'est ce qu'on appelle la tradition
la suite de la sounna lacenas attrition
les indices et les textes qui disent
comment se comporter le prophète alors
joué pour le drift conte à celle de
tamié sur l'île une souris la population
du texte est ce que ça je vais finir
parce que voilà l'explication de texte
ce n'est pas une erreur je connais quand
même un peu mieux ma religion que
monsieur donc la règle on appelle ça un
monsieur que je suis chercheur justement
sur les musulmans n'ont pas tous un peu
léger et on vient d'une famille
musulmane j'ai travaillé avec ce que je
donc je ne jetterai et la mosquée de
paris dommage donc j'ai eu plusieurs
sources et donc moi je m'intéresse aux
textes je m'intéresse pas la propagande
d'extrême droite ou être très claire les
hadiths qui dit être authentique il ya
toute une série de maladies ces textes
qui qui décrivent la vie du prophète un
oui c'est pas le texte du vin et des
prophètes ma femme m'a dit on ne sait
pas tout seul ce sens oui dames et
messieurs
vous disiez nairas 500 bars ce ne sont
pas des escrocs mais j'ai pas je vous
corrige lorsque vous écoutez par les
jeux sanitaire à 10 en arabe cher
monsieur pas bonne et nous la traduction
j'ai des ambitions sans cesse de ce mois
mais paraît direction batterie qui t'ai
parlé donc je finis ce que je dis ces
fameux a dit ce dont ils parlent qu'ils
sont une description de ce qui s'est
passé du temps du prophète ont été
reportés deux cents ans plus tard
l'authenticité de pas mal d'entre eux
peut être remis en question parce que
c'est pas des textes révélés
c'est pas des textes qui ont été
reconstitués tout de suite il a fait 200
ans pour ramener nos sims et les deux
personnes qui ont fait des recherches
pendant trente ans donc après on a mis
en ligne tout donné à 10 mais par contre
c'est ce propos qui est nue où on parle
de pédophilie
d c'est grave alors quand on fait un
blessé grave en effet que des gens n'est
pas fini j'ai pu parler tranquillement
avec vous c'est pas possible on va
s'arrêter quand même mais leur peine
mais clint écoutez donc j'ai fini mon
propos un historien et pas des rigolos
un historien sérieux vous expliquerai ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi le prophète
s'est marié avec au 9 11 femmes
c'était une question de stratégie
d'alliance avec des tribus donc c'est
uniquement pour ça la femme qui la
chérie elle avait 40 ans je le rappelle
dix ans de plus que lui alors quand vous
me sortez ce genre de d2 délire pour
essayer de salir une religion sur
samantha maintenant dormir sur ce sujet
quand même eu une fille de 16 ans fille
de 16 ans dérape
alors les insultes que vous avez
produite malheureusement sont
incomplètes j'ai tout entendu et
effectivement ça va très loin si c'était
juste ça bon c'est pas bien mais c'est
elle va beaucoup plus loin elle va dire
elle ne dit pas je critique la religion
comme ce qu'elle essaie de le rentrer à
page un peu minable classé derrière l
attaque des musulmans alors fort
contextualiser elle prend son premier
propose c'est de dire quoi moi et arabes
c'est pas moi mais c'est pas ma tasse de
thé ok très bien donc à une connotation
ethnique j'ai pas aimé
ensuite quelqu'un du jeu répond de
travers on n'a pas le détail et après
qu'est ce qui se passe
juste derrière commencé à insulter quoi
pas les religions l'islam alors gamme
alabina pour pour explication alors déjà
il ya une décision du génie ça il faut
bien le dire rapidement
voilà c'était pas effectivement
rendue rapidement accusé la justice
nous sommes en france vous accusez la
justice française de rendre des
décisions arbitraires j'étais mariée et
randonneurs de dire rapidement avec un
sous-entendu non je suis à côté de vous
j'ai entendu monsieur d'antan alors
accusé vous la justice française d'avoir
pris cette décision trop rapidement
est-ce que vous accusez la justice
française a condamné dreyfus enfin
arrêter le délire ça c'est pas la
perfection la justice française il ya
aussi des pressions du gouvernement
il ya aussi une pression sociale il ya
tout à traduire par une expression d'une
guerre de 25 ans elle a gardé ce genre
garder des douanes est allé dans le sens
effectivement elle était juste les
gardiens c'est tellement on lui a
reproché de deux ça ne peut pas
respecter l'indépendance de la justice
est plutôt d'aller dans le sens
effectivement la garde des sceaux est
dans son rôle elle est juste elle
garante des institutions l'indépendance
de la justice
après que ses pronos sur une chose parce
qu'elle est à la jetro si choqué si on
parle quand même pas de show gentil tout
est lisse et insultes violente
alors évidemment on ne va pas d'une
gamine on aimerait qu'elle avons la
justice a abandonné contre elle c'est
pour elle une caution personnelle une
opinion personnelle qui on le rappelle
n'est pas condamnée en france les appels
à la haine à l'incitation à la haine
qu'ils sont condamnés
cette jeune femme pourvus ce pour notre
information expliqué avoir tenu ces
propos à avoir été après avoir été
insulté harcelés par des internautes
voilà alors on va pas se substituer à la
justice ici effectivement mais est ce
que ça veut dire tout simplement d'être
payés on ne peut plus critiqué toutes
les religions et que c'est totalement
explosif ce sont des sujets qui sont
envoyées c'est vrai que voilà c'est un
petit peu dur à l'ambiance cap sur
france inter sur france inter radio du
service public français nous avons
entendu cette chanson tout à fait idiot
minutieuse jésus et [ __ ] oui quelle a été
la réaction de la conférence des évêques
de france
je prends at on eu une réaction il faut
pouvoir at on eu une réaction égale à
celle du délégué général du cfcm qui a
osé dire sur un plateau de radio elle
l'a bien cherché
elle doit assumer les conséquences de ce
qu'elle a dit bon il ya un obstacle
lorsque lorsque le père jacques hamel a
été assassiné nivard un terroriste à
bord le temps de l'islam quelle a été la
réaction de la conférence des évêques de
france et en particulier de l'archevêque
de paris c'était une réalité dont il
tombe un jour en dignité et en mesurer
coeur va mauvais meurillon avoir en
france des musulmans comme nos
catholique
c'est à dire des musulmans monsieur mais
soumis non non seulement les catholiques
sont soumis aujourd'hui à la morale
juridique donc sur le plateau de ruches
cavigal que la référence
je rêve de france j10 ils ont soumis à
l'adulte et le catholicisme français
cher monsieur vous et vous insulter le
cadre de sa journée ça c'est une blague
on va on va essayer aussi de tuteurs
effectué jeudi un retour à l'ordinaire
ce débat doit donc canada laïcité à sous
mais l'aurait appelé l'église catholique
donc pour vous la laisse six mois par
combat pour l'histoire la santé est une
mesure de soumission de l'église
catholique
issoire mais vous connaissez pas
l'histoire
yoro sow vision de l'érosion des aires
d'accueil gamin la vie naquet préciser
votre pensée orange fédérer sans le
calme et on aime jean le cam et point il
a du mal à sa quête des origines
j'essaie de le calmer parce qu'il disait
beaucoup de bêtises et les lignes
rondouillardes quand on est ignorant
d'histoire on parle pas comme ça donc je
commence par le début
effectivement 1905 par une voix ils ont
je parle de la gauche écarté l'église de
l'éducation ils ont écarté du pouvoir
ils ont écarté de tous les moyens de
pression qui l'état avaient ils ont
libéré l'état de l'église c'est une
réalité ça voulu passer comme ça la
laïcité c'est fonder non pas pour
apaiser les tensions n'allez plus en
france elle s'est fondée uniquement pour
écarter des vis de l'état c'est tout ça
vous plaît pas pour la boukha vous allez
adorer
ensuite deuxième chose concernant vos
écarts vous allez parler des terroristes
je vois pas le rapport avec le sujet je
veux dire c'est pas parce qu'elle de
trois excités tarek qui ont été ratés
dans la vie qui ont pris décalage en se
revendiquant d'un d'une est venu ce
qu'ils connaissent même pas qu'il faut
confondre ça avec avec le reste j'ai
parlé d'une histoire qui vous
intéressait hélas à vous intéresser
on a fait monter en épingle une fille de
16 ans qui est insultante une ailleurs
pourquoi suite ça se règle pas ce qui
était dit c'est beaucoup plus grave
ok ça ça mérite la une ça mérite pas la
une il ya une fille qui a été violée il
ya un mois par deux voyous donc jeune
maghrébine
elle a été filmée sur cela chat ça
aurait dû faire le tour des médias parce
que les médias les réseaux sociaux font
monter en épingle des choses sales sales
on n'a pas parlé pourquoi on n'a pas
parlé pourtant été violée c'est grave il
ya un garçon qui était tué par deux
voyous en banlieue il a été jeté dans le
canal de l'ourcq et ça a été filmé sur
cette chatte ça fait marrer toutes les
racailles sauf ce valeureux sa famille
pour qu'on n'en parle pas de ça là il ya
mort d'homme il ya une femme qui a été
violée peau causée par là dessus alors
on va parler une jeune fille qui a
déconnecté des icaunais qui a provoqué
parce qu'on l'a provoquée ok on
l'approché pourquoi parce que madame
j'ai appelé aujourd'hui 1 qu'elle était
homosexuel revendiqué a le droit
chère madame combien de viols y at il en
france tous les jours
violent et at il en france où les gens y
compris filmé et diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux
la différence entre cette affaire qui
est un faits divers et la ferme il a
fait que la paire milla et politique
elle touche elle touche à la liberté de
blasphémer la termina à une dimension
politique vous le savez très bien je
sais pas vous vous le savez que je
vénère de récupérer qualité la dimension
politique d'un violent filmées et
diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux il y à
lui il ya eu il devient une femme il y a
eu plusieurs lois justement dès le mans
séries entre les violences sexuelles et
je vous répète sauvage dans quel
contexte cette jeune femme at elle été
violée et filmé à payer moins cher
monsieur
dans quel contexte moi on me dit non je
ne sais pas c'est vous plaît avait lancé
ce sujet je vous explique enel a été
violée dans le contexte de l'obsession
d'exister sur internet et sur la jeune
fille était saviola de voyous qui était
d'ouvrir deux voyous mais qui qui je
vois lui j'ai pas lent d'où leur prénom
c'est comme ça que je suis monsieur
j'allais vous n'avez moi j'aimerais lui
la chine ont annoncé maintenant alinto
gère mesdames c'est à dire que vous avez
aujourd'hui en banlieue dans ce temps
dans le bout de nombreux territoires
français à majorité musulmane où un pays
qui subissent des violences sexuelles
ont également des mutilations sexuelles
je vous rappelle qu'à londres il y
encore quelques mois il y avait un
procès pour excision et que leur dicte
mes chers messieurs les violents avaient
déjà forte mais là c'est que j'ai une
parade d'homosexuels et je vous dis pas
les rues par des violences sexuelles en
france sont commises dans un contexte
musulmans ces races et moulis et raciste
mais n'allez pas dire à ce jeu vient
d'hériter du mmm n 1 des bleus
d'égaliser la vérité sont désistés
la plupart des femmes qui sont tués en
france on a la liste dommage
les islamistes bizarrement c'est le nom
de européenne ça veut dire que
majoritairement pas tout
il ya 10% d'étrangères et les
européennes les mecs violents dans le
monde entier ont des comportements
violents vis-à-vis des femmes et c'est
les sagouins c'est tout lui qu'est ce
que j'en ramène en a bien sûr matin dans
les bonnes nouvelles une femme battue à
vous êtes une femme d'affaires
choisi français c'est connaissent une
année il a battu à saint denis
quels sont vos moyens quelles sont vos
valeurs tout le monde mais la police
avec la police c'était assez compliqué
justement il y avait peu des coudes sur
ces questions de violence conjugale est
effectivement le cas n'avait pas l'air
pour le coup particulier en seine saint
denis et non c'est que monsieur nous dit
que les journalistes nous dit dans les
quartiers musulmans parce qu'il ya du
quartier musulman c'est l'arrivée ce
nouveau quartier à majorité musulmane il
ya eu qu'à rediriger un cas maghrébine
sont pas tous musulmans dans ces
quartiers là il y aurait soi-disant une
sorte de syndrome ça me rappelle au
camel chaufferie que je me connais
beaucoup de chrétiens d'algérie ou du
maroc de tunisie a gelé dans les
décombres aujourd'hui dans les quartiers
attaques des musulmans je les
légendaires testés sont musulmans au
nord pourraient convoler sont musulmans
non l'élite mais c'est un truc de fou
la vérité c'est qu'il ya très peu de
personnes d'origine maghrébine qui ont
une religion différente bien femme
fatale dans les rues hier à l'égard d'un
mois le rival dans les services et dans
les cités impopulaire c'est comme ça
qu'ils s'appellent il ya des
concentrations d'étrangers les portugais
sont musulmans mais jamais les espagnols
sont musulmans ils sont longs mois vous
allez vous et d'oser dire dans les
quartiers à majorité musulmane c'est là
où j'ai le plus de viol ça s'appelle du
racisme non genesis cher monsieur que
aujourd'hui dire qu'en réalité il ya une
actualité sa violence sexuelle en
relation avec l'histoire mensonge non
mais bon dans son élément dans les bas
de toute façon vous les traces a décoré
en à patxi compliqué un gamin la
ménagère aux équipements est ce que
effectivement aujourd'hui est ce qu'il
est plus compliqué peut-être c'est
l'accusation en tout cas de votre
contradicteur à côté est-ce qu'il est
plus compliqué de ont souhaité poser
cette question à l'époque de charlie
hebdo de critiquer l'islam en france et
seront pas contraintes équipiers mahomet
ce qu'on peut critiquer les tentatives
c'est une chose mais il ya une
différence entre critiquer et insulter
à l'époque nous a fait coup de je suis
charlie m'attend si je suis milhas
encore plus ridicule saison bref un à
fait ridicule
charlie china ce n'est pas fini jean
vous venez de formation juridique hull
cela s'appelle un comparatif de
supériorité ça veut dire que charlie
hebdo je suis charlie était ridicule et
je pèse aussi nous laisse encore plus
ridicule que je suis là à l'extrême
droite nationale c'est scandaleux je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire ça il y a eu
beau dans la niche de grappes beaucoup
de choses sur lui mort met en demeure
l'ex de la rédaction de charité de
synosia ben hamida juste pour finir
rapidement donc jean prochaine en f1
avant des coups qu'on va jeudi à
l'époque on nous a intimé d'être charlie
et aujourd'hui je suis mis lac kir ai
dit que je sais je suis là qui nous
intime et on vous a obligé dont pas un
film est synonyme d'obliger oui je suis
bien et qu'elle était de français la
connaissent assez bien la langue y
mettre pour autant m'anime d'obliger
pour visa oblige être je finis on a que
je veux dire par myriam el arabi n'a
rien donné sinon tout ce que j'ai alors
je me kiffe
je veux dire simplement c'est que par
rapport à charlie on les a dit vous êtes
vous êtes avec nous ou contre ses idées
alors c'est pas comme ça que j'ai dit
des choses on doit réfléchir en disant
ya quoi moi je suis canard enchaîné
rappelle terre j'adorais cabu dommages
ont été tués donc j'adorerais cabu mais
j'adorais cabu dans le canard dommage
donc dans assez juste pourquoi plutôt
mauvaise et ridicule et je pense qu'il
ya mémoire en cas d'événement les mots
révélateurs
dommage de l'importance dommage pour
vous j'adorais cabu dommage pour vous
traduisez du mal oui vous avez mais je
veux dire bon rythme avec le français
vous êtes donc j'ai pour damas hama en
plus d'être assistant à ben non non et
non marxiste il y aura six n'importe
quoi je ne me résigne et moi ça fait
rigoler bref bon qui se passe c'est que
à l'époque y avez vous êtes vous pour ou
contre charlie moi j'ai dit que j'aimais
pas charlie hebdo pourquoi pas parce que
tu es des distillateurs je suis baissier
trois bandes dessinées dommage donc tuer
des dessinateurs c'est inique
c'est intolérable en revanche moi ma
préférence est exportée sur le canard
enchaîné parce que je rigolais que le
canard enchaîné charlie hebdo ne faisait
pas rire merci comme bourvil et louis de
funès on n'a pas le même humour c'est
une question du mot là ça devient quoi
si vous n'êtes pas chargée vous êtes un
criminel un terroriste mais c'est quoi
ce délire
moi j'ai aucun rapport avec ces gens là
les racailles de banlieue qui sortent et
calage pour tuer les gens je le déteste
l'autoroute sans partage est monsieur se
lire ipad
ce sont des musulmans orthodoxes nancy
sort des notes
orthodoxes absolument qu'ils pratiquent
le rite surgit pratique âme de carbone
rite sunnite qui pratiquent des
catholiques sunnite à la lettre à la
lettre comme on le pratique du maroc
d'ailleurs à la lettre rabat au maroc
absolument vous êtes ignorant du maroc
vis avant cette union du maroc que ça va
vous êtes ignorant que passe-t-il pour
les musulmans qui quittent l'islam au
maroc
l'apostasié l apostasie de lesquin
claude monet à la peine de mort selon le
droit marocain monsieur peut-être le
maroc ne l'a pas pratiqué sali les mains
d'être à peut-être peut-être il ne l'a
pas pratiqué mais on peut aussi le froid
annoncé femmes en france un tony parker
napoléon est ce qu'on l'à pic non c'est
ridicule donc pour revenir à ce que je
disais quand monsieur ne connais pas la
banlieue il la connaît pas du tout quand
monsieur caricature abonnés pour être ni
6 et dire c'est majoritairement musulman
c'est qu'il ait jamais été et comme la
chine gt rien n'est jamais évident et je
vis à paris allait relocaliser à paris
et je me déplace régulièrement en
banlieue parisienne à neuilly c'est pas
la banlieue mais si seulement j'avais le
faut aller au verbier
je vais tous les nombreux escaliers je
vais tous les lames dit étudier à
aubervilliers à la maison des sciences
de l'homme cher monsieur dont vous voyez
c'est mal par la magie bear de match
olivier de l'ach donald encore mais plus
sérieusement quand quelqu'un nous réduit
une question de violence féminine et ça
c'est gravissime
en disant ce n'est pas réduit je le
réduis souhaite aujourd'hui c'est de
jouer n vous êtes ridicules mais on va
on va retrouver l'élite
aujourd'hui il y a aujourd'hui hier et
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui by lm de
violence de violence à l'encontre des
femmes en masse culié de violences
sexuelles à l'encontre des femmes en
relation avec l'islam
et quand on parle de violence sexuelle
ça n'est pas que le voile ce sont aussi
les mutilations sexuelles je vous
rappelle le travail extraordinaire de
l'île d'abate curiel qui est secrétaire
général de la ligue du droit
international des femmes dans les
départements de beauvoir l'oeuf le kia
pratiqués dans ces cas là
a fait interdire l'excision en france
l'excision est parti et dans les délais
qualité
combien aujourd'hui vous avez des
mesures qui ont été mises en place
justement pour pouvoir identifier les
jeunes filles qui sont menacés de
l'excision ou qui ont déjà subi ou a
déjà essoré d'excision ils sont sûrement
bien delphi en seconde ou deux dizaines
de milliers de films madame et je vous
invite à aller sur le site de la ligue
du droit international des femmes il ya
un rapport tout à fait détaillé sur le
sujet aujourd'hui a même des discussions
franco allemandes des discussions
franco-allemandes très sérieuse dans le
bar de latéral à des bateaux sur le
problème de l'excision et des violences
mal encadré ci parce que monsieur et
ignorants de la chose et qui sont
pratiqués par les pays subsahariens
c'est pas une tradition musulmane
contrairement aux mensonges qu elle
préférait les gîtes la pratique un peu
malheureusement elle est condamnée par
les musulmans et toutes les écoles de
condamne parce que ça n'a rien à voir
avec la circoncision l'excision est une
mutilation qui est condamnable
malheureusement et qui est dans les
traditions qui était préexisté à l'islam
ça monsieur vous dira pas parce qu'il ne
sait pas donc entier par l'excision me
fait rigoler visionner cela pratiqué par
les chrétiens au soudan ni par les
arabes
elle n'est pas pratiqué par l'église
dans les arbres mais les draps les
pratiques par exemple mans elle est
parfaitement ragon kebab ou soudan et en
egypte les coptes ne pratique par
l'exclusion les caf tenue près de paris
mode et d'art on y reçoit famille là bas
je le dis franchement je condamne le
fait qu'on les fait monter en épingle
une affaire qui ont dû rester privées je
condamne à fait elle aurait dû justement
ne pas intervenir fermée celle roches
les sauveteurs poliment la garde des
sceaux de maladie c'est un peu ça
malheureusement ce qui est beaucoup de
maladresse dans dossier mais en réalité
moi ce que je note c'est qu'est-ce que
j'ai dès ce matin la radio c'est que
cette jeune fille 16 ans donc la saison
on n'est pas fort mais politiquement
elle a fait un coude réaction c'est une
réaction épidermique à la nuit je la
comprends parce qu'on la suite est
semble-t-il son homosexualité après sa
réaction a été extrêmement
disproportionnée vis-à-vis des crétins
qui ont attaqué de l'autre côté
l'éthique et la masse des versions des
crétins et a pas de discuter accepter
que quelques actes et paroles grossières
passé continuent pour trouver
il a elle a eu une parole grossia à
l'encontre de qui est ce que le coran
est ce que le bois est une personnalité
juridique est ce que vous connaissez
est-ce que sur les finalités juridique à
la non tout à l'en croire s'il est
interdit d'attaquer des personnes
réellement gala ne pas qu'elles
acquièrent monsieur lang a été classé
les recrutements ce passé que c'est pas
le problème savoir ce qui est ou pas ce
qu'ils ont sous coup la loi c'est pour
ça aussi ça blesse ou pas moi j'allais
dire quand quelqu'un insulte jésus
dommage mais sa famille la coupe et
c'est génial car ainsi de diviser et à
chaque fois il s'énerve
donc quand quelqu'un insulte de jésus je
trouve que c'est intolérable et les
nazis quand on insulte hitler trouve
c'est intolérable aussi charme alors
alors alors là non non non non du temps
du front national aux cantonales canton
à ce phénomène trouve ça inacceptable
également en quoi mao mais tu es plus
sacré que n'importe quel autre homme sur
cette planète parce qu'il ya un milliard
d'individus on y croirait personne
évidemment ce n'est pas plus sacrée à ce
qu'il ya pour les bouddhistes de bouddha
est sacré pour les chrétiens jésus est
sacrée pour eux mais cher monsieur et je
brise est sacrée et célébrer mais j'ai
un champ mais nous vivions dans une
république laïque
nous n'avons pas à votre honneur nous
n'avons pas à reconnaître la saxo
la qualité des mythes si la république
respecte les cultes les gens vous ne la
respecte pas merci on termine la gamme
alabina un abbé rhallouch pour ce débat
plus qu'animé merci à bout en tout cas
on se retrouve dans 5 minutes pour un
nouveau journal
[Musique]
et
c'est quoi pour vous fils république
éthique écoutez c'est une république qui
se préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption contre la fraude fiscale qui
a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme
pin-up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et ccc sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation le citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs sont joués mais les rex
ne sont pas toujours respectées les
couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
je suis avec rohmer et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
[Musique]
à bientôt sur rt france
dans le mouvement des gilet jaune
ça a commencé avec une pétition que j'ai
lancé le 29 mai démons 18 qu'il est
lancée la hausse des taxes sur le
carburant
j'ai commencé à partager massivement la
pétition à la en septembre j'ai pensé à
une chose toute bête c'est qu'on a le
gilet jaune dans la voiture qui est
obligatoire depuis quelques années et je
me suis dit que ça pourrait être un très
bon code couleur c'est avec ça que le
président macron nous répond aujourd'hui
en france quand on veut juste un peu
plus d'eux de justice de dignité humaine
et d'égalité
au départ on était question de l'action
manifestations blocages francs etc et
aujourd'hui on fait des manifestations
et des débats les manifestations et des
assemblées les manifestations et des
réunions
j'espère que le président va enfin
sortir de sa cachette et affronter le
problème à la souche toiture a pas une
confiance absolue dans pourra jamais
s'arrêter comme ça
comment avoir confiance aujourd'hui en
un président qui nous a tiré dessus ça
ça va être très très difficile je pense
[Applaudissements]
ici on l'appelle la tour de david et
pour beaucoup de gens c'est l'endroit le
plus sûr de la capitale du venezuela
pourtant célèbre pour des taux de
criminalité urbaine très élevé 2500
personnes sans abri ont occupé ce
gratte-ciel inachevé du centre de
caracas
ils en ont chassé les criminels et
organiser leur propre coopérative
d'habitation
[Musique]
il
c'est le sentiment que que vous avez eue
vous aussi ce besoin d'autonomie
oui complètement besoin d'autonomie
besoin de retourner à des choses plus
essentielles en fait est vraiment de
sentir qu'on n'est pas forcément un
poids pour la planète
il ya une idée derrière il ya une
philosophie aussi qu'on a vu la serre
les plantes qui poussent le fait de
vivre avec les plantes comme ça vraiment
commune comme une machine un organisme
pour fait partie de celles de cet
organisme
on a eu vraiment l'impression de se
construire en même temps quand vous
construisez cette maison en faisant
toutes ces rencontres et je pense que
ces genres de projets qui se fait pas
tout seul dans son coin on est dans un
truc vraiment de coopération de partage
de partage
[Musique]
edouard philippe a bon espoir un premier
l'issue de la conférence de financement
lancée aujourd'hui à paris perturbé par
plusieurs dizaines d'opposants à la
réforme des retraites avant même
l'expiration des délais quelques 10,7 me
damon amendements sur le projet de
réforme ont été déposées
l'examen du texte en commission un
record sous cette législature
au royaume uni un réveil du break 6 puis
une réunion ii
l'union européenne après trois ans et
demi d'un feuilleton mouvementé londres
succès jusqu'à la fin de l'année pour
renégocier les conditions de son départ
alors que certains promettaient un
désastre l'économie britannique se porte
nettement mieux que prévu le coronavirus
déjà de plus au moins 170 personnes en
chine alors que le web est ce à décréter
l'urgence internationale
certains et à faire leur frontière avec
la chine et les compagnies there
commence à suspendre leurs vols vers le
pays en france un sixième cas étaient
confirmés ce soir mais vous possible
épidémie là dans l'hexagone a été
écartée mais là les [ __ ] demeure
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt francs
si vous nous rejoignez 12 milliards
d'euros par an d'ici 2027 c'est
l'objectif de la conférence de
financement du système des retraites
voulue par laurent berger la cmdt s est
ouverte tout à l'heure au conseil
économique social et environnemental
réunis autour du gouvernement les
partenaires sociaux qui doivent se
mettre d'accord d'ici avril pour
équilibrer le régime des retraites et à
l'extérieur plusieurs dizaines
d'opposants à la réforme manifestent
leur métro centre ont écouté certains
d'entre eux au micro de green arrow
sydonia pour le nôtre quand sociale pour
les travailleurs les travailleuses et la
genèse
elle débouchera sur rien de toute façon
la clé pour nous pour une vie meilleure
un présent un avenir meilleur c'est
l'issue de ce conflit
c'est l'issue de cette grève est donc
l'issue positive de ses rêves
c'est le retrait ni amendable ni
négociable c'est pourquoi on pense
aujourd'hui que une partie de
l'intersyndicale qui a choisi qu'a
accepté d'y participer elle a rien à y
faire et on aurait des 5 décembre tous
les jours on ne serait ce qu'une semaine
macron il rigolerait un petit peu
différemment et probablement qu'il
aurait même eu le temps d'aller au
théâtre ceux qui croient en ce projet là
la cfdt et l'unsa qui va nous expliquer
que finalement il ya des avancées
possibles qui sont prêts à négocier sur
la réforme des retraites actuelles
lorsque le financement d'un tel conseil
d'état il vient dire que cette retraite
7,7 ce projet de loi il tient pas la
route et que sainte un travail d'amateur
commence à ceux qui viennent encore
négocier ce ce set cette réforme ce
n'est pas possible c'est inconcevable ou
alors ça veut dire qu'on a à faire aussi
à des syndicats amateurs et la sortie de
cette réunion le premier ministre
edouard philippe s'est exprimée s'est
montré confiant en phase avec alvaro
collaboration entre le gouvernement les
partenaires sociaux et annoncé une
prochaine réunion pour le 10 février
nous avons indiqué que nous étions prêts
évidemment à entendre prendre en compte
les analyses financières qui serait
proposé soit par les organisations
syndicales soit par les organisations
patronales et je veux encore une fois
salué le sens des responsabilités des
partenaires sociaux et dire que j'ai
confiance dans la capacité que nous
avons collectivement en travaillant en
nous écoutant
en évoluant peut-être chacun à partir
des positions qui sont d'une autre à
trouver un compromis et donc à arriver
au terme d'une conférence sur
l'équilibré sur le financement qui est
un des moments importants de cette
réforme
j'ai par ailleurs indiqué aux
partenaires sociaux comme je m'y étais
engagé au mois de janvier qu'une réunion
multilatérale serait organisée à
matignon dans la semaine du 10 février
qui permettra de faire un point d'étape
est peut-être deux conclure sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui sont
travaillés en ce moment par le
gouvernement et les partenaires sociaux
dans le domaine de la pénibilité des
départs progressifs à la retraite dans
le domaine du travail sur les
transitions des systèmes actuels vers le
système universel et sur la question des
minimum contributif c'est à dire sur la
question des petites retraites garanties
à l'ensemble des actifs sur ces points
la discussion est intense elle se
poursuit alors en ait encore quelques
réunions organisées dans les jours qui
viennent mais il m'a semblé utile que
dans la semaine du 10 février nous
puissions nous retrouver pour faire le
point le cas échéant pour conclure de
façon à ce que à l'assemblée nationale
dès la séance publique les éléments
éventuelle de conclusion en tout cas les
éléments d'avancé puissent être pris en
compte ce sujet écoute et d'analystes
d'anne marie guillemard sociologue
professeur émérite à l'université paris
descartes sorbonne expert au conseil
d'orientation des retraites
on est rentré à nouveau dans une réforme
paramétrique comme on en a eu toute une
série depuis 2003 à moins de cette
réforme quand même depuis 2003 et tout
paramétrique et donc les mesures d'âge
se réinstalle comme comme élément
central de la négociation pourquoi
faut-il faire des économies alors que
l'idée et c'est ce que disait jean-paul
delvoye pour une fois en france on fait
une réforme à coût constant 14% du pime
l'effort français était selon le cor
conseil d'orientation des retraites 14%
du pipe jusqu'en 2070 accueil houleux à
angoulême pour emmanuel macron en visite
à l'occasion du festival international
de la bande dessinée près de 200
personnes ont tenté d'interpeller le
président
ils ont été repoussés par un important
dispositif de police ils protestaient
contre la réforme des retraites
parmi eux olivier faure le premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste
ce pays est le sentiment de n'être
jamais écouté le plus jeune république
n'a pas été simplement sur le programme
il a d'abord fait elle face à marine le
pen
et parce que pour nous les parages
l'expérience donne pas une carte blanche
pour détruire modèle social français 113
cette photo du chef de l'état qui étonne
emmanuel macron a posé avec un t-shirt
dénonçant les tirs de l bd offert par le
dessinateur hors jeu le président s'en
est expliqué nous sommes en désaccord
mais on est dans une société libre dans
laquelle on peut poser avec un t-shirt
avec lequel on n'est pas d'accord
ce t-shirt dit que dans notre pays la
liberté d'expression est protégé quand
des violences ont lieu les policiers
doivent être sanctionnées si leurs actes
sont avérés mais je récuse le terme de
violences policières
la violence est d'abord dans la société
exclusion de cédric villani à paris
groupe parlementaire au délicat pour la
république en marche
le point avec leïla c'est une période
difficile pour le parti des manuels
macron d'abord des municipales pas si
simple à gérer
sans surprise cédric villani candidat
dissident de la république en marche à
paris a été exclu du parti par le bureau
exécutif mercredi soir la république en
marche prend acte que cédric villani
n'est plus membre du parti suite à ses
propos sans ambiguïté et son envie de
maintenir sa candidature librement le
bureau en a tiré les conséquences tout
en regrettant la situation le mouvement
a tendu la main à cédric villani
jusqu'au bout et continuera à oeuvrer au
rassemblement de tous ses adhérents et
adhérentes mais il n'ya pas que la
capitale qui suscite des interrogations
à biarritz le ministre de l'agriculture
didier guillaume et le secrétaire d'état
au tourisme et au commerce extérieur
jean baptiste lemoyne tous deux prêts à
s'affronter ont été priés de se retirer
le ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics gérald darmanin c'est lui
clairement positionné à tourcoing après
avoir beaucoup parlé avec l'équipe
municipale jeu
mènerait la liste aux élections
municipales à tourcoing le président
emmanuel macron m'a autorisé à être en
campagne électorale
si je suis tête de liste c'est pour être
mère une façon de laisser entendre qu'il
pourrait quitter le gouvernement dans un
avenir proche
lui qui avait déjà été élu maire de
tourcoing en 2014 sous l'étiquette ump
changer de bord quitter le navire des
initiatives qui ne sont pas rares au
sein de l air eau m le parti compte
actuellement 300 de membres et
apparentés à l'assemblée nationale alors
qu'ils étaient 313 en 2017
de tout temps les groupes politiques ont
connu des défections ou des frondes
comme ceux hollande ou même de gaulle
mais l'usagé était de rester dans le
parti
la différence c'est que lrm n'a pas la
solidité nécessaire pour garder ses
députés et eux n'ont pas eu le temps de
s'attacher au mouvement né en 2016 le
lien est plus superficielle donc plus
facile à rompre emmanuel macron qui
s'est tenu publiquement à distance des
municipales nous commandent pas encore
ces départs reste à savoir si la
motivation et la cohésion au sein du
parti présidentiel sont toujours aussi
fortes et il faut tony barbeau aux
conseillers de paris ancien sénateur lui
n'est pas surpris de voir plusieurs
députés quitter le parti présidentiel
j'utilise donc la réforme des retraites
devait avoir lieu j'espère qu'elle aura
lieu mais c'est vrai qu'actuellement
pour beaucoup de confusion enfin moi je
vois ça comme observateur et j'espère
qu'on trouvera des solutions alors tant
mieux si ce que dit le premier promu
nice éric il y souvent il a besoin de se
rassurer dû rassurer les français
j'espère que ce qu'il dit est vrai on
verra bien mais il ya quand même le
débat au parlement on a une
interrogation du sénat qui se disait
kika même est un peu interrogatif sur le
fait que 14 personnes pib n'a pas de
simulation financière activement le
débat aussi à l'assemblée je crois que
même aux côtés à amateurs dans cette
gestion des choses là ça a été des
parlementaires choisis sur internet
évidemment ils arrivent ils découvrent
un monde qui est pas le leur est tout à
fait normal si vous voulez que
qui est une crise au sein de ce
parlement petit à petit prennent
conscience si vous voulez qu'ils sont un
peu d'aidé que des relais d'une action
qui ne maîtrisent pas et beaucoup se
réajuste je trouve d'ailleurs quand il
du fait qu'ils avaient choisi
pratiquement tôt la parlementaire sur
sur internet je trouve qu'il n'est que
18 sont partis c'est toujours ce déjà
donc c'est pas extraordinaire mais
excusez moi mais c'est un peu logique
quand on crée pas un parti politique on
crée pas parlement un rapport sur
internet et tout ça ça est ridicule
après trois ans et demi d'un feuilleton
riche en rebondissements le royaume uni
fait enfin sombre excite ce sera demain
à 23h l'on se donne jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour renégocier ses relations
avec l'union européenne un moment choisi
par washington pour se rapprocher de
londres le chef de la diplomatie
américaine mec pompéo rencontre le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson hier les députés européens eux
ont ratifié l'accord de retrait notre
reporter sur place bcm chebbi car nous
n'avons pas peur du débat
nous considérons que ce débat parce
qu'elle était à vivre les britanniques
demain 31 janvier va marquer une date
historique dans l'histoire de la grande
bretagne sa sortie de l'union européenne
après des années de discussions et de
débats houleux avec bruxelles les
britanniques quitteront ce 31 janvier
définitivement l'union européenne des
festivités seront organisées ici même à
londres sur le parvis de wesminster des
prises de paroles des débats des
concerts et même des faisceaux lumineux
qui seront projetés pour représenter
bigben car big ben ne sonnera pas big
ben est en travaux plusieurs festivités
et activités seront organisées tout au
long de la journée puis ce sera au tour
de boris johnson à partir de 23h de
prendre la parole un discours à la
nation pour célébrer cet acte historique
comme il le dit lui-même et puis un
cadran sera projeté sur la façade du 10
downing street pardon pour symboliser
big ben et surtout symbolisé les dix
coups de minuit ceux qui représenteront
en août un tournant historique pour la
grande bretagne et sa sortie de l'union
européenne une événement historique qui
divise les anglais entre les probables
des propres excite pardon elle est
gentil est vrai qu'ils étaient non
sur le parvis de westmister depuis le
début de l'après midi acclamés leur
appartenance à l'union européenne avec
des drapeaux de l'union européenne et
les slogans hostiles à boris johnson et
puis certains députés ont décidé de
prolonger cette soirée historique pour
les anglais avec une soirée dans un
restaurant avec au menu des plats
typiquement britannique du vin à
britannique dans une atmosphère
complètement britannique
pour célébrer cet événement historique
la sortie de la grande-bretagne de
l'union européenne et be c'est une
sortie qui prendra bien sûr du temps le
divorce est acté mais reste à construire
il prendra environ 11 mois 11 mois
qu'ils permettront à la grande bretagne
de sortir définitivement de l'union
européenne et d'amorcer leur avenir
l écosse aussi toute l'union européenne
un triste jour pour sa population qui
s'était largement prononcés contre le
break site
je suis vraiment déprimé par ce qui va
arriver demain et j'essaye de ne pas y
penser
ces nouveaux 50 pence qu'ils vont mettre
en circulation pour moi ce n'est pas une
monnaie légale
quand je vois le break site je vois les
états unis d'abord toutes ces politiques
sont vraiment préjudiciable aux efforts
que nous devons faire pour résoudre les
problèmes mondiaux
je pense donc que c'est une chose très
négative je ne veux pas que cela se
produise
comme la plupart des écossais j'ai
l'impression que ma voix n'a pas été
entendu en tant que pays nous avons été
exclus
nous n'avons pas de voir west nile tard
donc non je ne veux pas que cela se
produise je préfère rester au sein de
l'union européenne
orleans format l'eurodéputé membre du
parti conservateur l'économie
britannique a des chances de prospérer
par conséquent de donner des idées à
d'autres pays de l'union européenne oui
pouces mais je pense certainement que
nous serons punis plus infectées dont
nous devrons à conclure des accords
d'une version non bâti je pense que
relativement court terme robben
prospérer et que le reste de l'europe à
nice observée très attentivement car si
nous nous en sortons bien et je pense
que cela sera le cas d'autres ce dur est
peut-être regarder et laura élus ni
peut-être que nous devrions les elite n
ont pas besoin d'être dans l'union
européenne
pour prospérer et je pense que l'union
va commencer à se détricoter nous
pourrons alors avoir une nouvelle
relation
oubliez le fédéralisme et les
dysfonctionnements de cette monnaie
unique pas fonctionner à la fois pour
l'allemagne et pour la grèce donc le cap
que prend européen créé des dangers et
du ressentiment mais à l'extrémisme
l'union européenne doit se réformer en
profondeur
et pourtant elle refuse donc le
président sera peut-être le déclencheur
d'une nouvelle vague de coopération
le royaume uni qui espère un
rapprochement économique avec les états
unis c'est le but de la visite de mike
pompéo à londres mais certains sujets ne
plaisent pas à washington comme l'accès
de huawei au réseau 100g accordé mardi
par le royaume uni or c'est laid mais
aussi ses recommandations à l'égard du
géant chinois
alexandra gomez avec karzaï alors que la
5g arrive en europe son déploiement
inquiète bruxelles parmi les entreprises
plébiscité pour sa mise en place
huawei mais le groupe chinois suscite la
méfiance du vieux continent à l'instar
des états unis qui ont exclu huawei de
la 5g des pays de l'union européenne
redoute un espionnage au profit de pékin
aujourd'hui
donc oui il ya des préoccupations
relatives à ce réseau enfin cette
entreprise qui est on ne sait pas trop
quelles sont ses biens avec le réseau
chinois mais et en plus on ne sait pas
trop si elle dispose de danser réseau de
portes qu'on appelle de porte dérobée
vers les services de renseignement du
gouvernement chinois mais en tout cas
cette entreprise est là et on a
plusieurs responsables européens
s'inquiètent d'une loi chinoise de 2017
obligeant les entreprises du pays à
coopérer avec les services de
renseignement seul londres s'est exprimé
sur la marche à suivre dans la lignée
des consignes de bruxelles exclure
huawei des bases militaires et de sites
nucléaires et limiter ses parts de
marché à 35%
nous légiférons dès que possible pour
limiter et contrôler la présence de
vendeurs à haut risque dans le réseau
britannique et pour nous permettre de
réagir à l'évolution des technologies
avec le temps notre intention est de
réduire la part de marché des vendeurs à
hauts risques au fur et à mesure que le
marché se diversifiera express
les pays de l'union européenne
recommande de privilégier les
entreprises européennes comme nokia et
ericsson principaux concurrents de
huawei pour la 5g en attendant le
chinois s'est déjà félicitée de la
décision de l'union européenne
huawei se félicite de la décision de
l'europe qui lui permet de continuer à
participer au déploiement de la 5g
cette approche objective est basée sur
les faits en matière de sécurité
permettra à l'europe de disposer d'un
réseau 5g plus sûr et plus rapide
cependant le calendrier du déploiement
de la 5g lui reste flou en france il
devrait être effectif au cours du
deuxième semestre 2001 autorisé avec
restriction la 5g hawaï où de manière
pour londres et bruxelles de ne pas trop
l'idée étant de ne pas se couper du
marché américain mais de pas non plus se
froisser avec le marché chinois qui est
aujourd'hui prépondérant
c'est une position d'équilibriste entre
bas certains arguments qui peuvent
s'entendre notamment sur la protection
et la sûreté de dd des sites les plus
sensibles notamment les sites militaires
et puis de l'autre côté on ne l'interdît
pas tout développement de webos sur le
territoire européen ou anglais est ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'on
a la même que la même problématique la
même question est quasiment la même
réponse
alors que les anglais sont en train de
le rue le ms décret de ce soir l'urgence
internationale face aux nouveaux
coronavirus pour lutter contre sa
propagation la russie annonce son
intention de fermer ces quelques 4000
250 km de frontière avec la chine pour
revenir sur la situation écoutez les
précisions d'antoine clairon à moscou
la cellule de crise créée en début de
semaine par le premier ministre russe
michail michou style est désormais
opérationnel et plusieurs mesures ont
d'ores et déjà été adoptées ainsi à
compter du 31 janvier
certaines sections de la frontière entre
la chine et la russie seront fermées à
la circulation
autant pour les véhicules que pour les
piétons le trafic ferroviaire entre les
deux pays est également suspendu à
l'exception notable de la liaison moscou
pékin concernant les vols depuis et vers
la chine les contrôles ont été renforcés
dans les aéroports et les ministres
russes de l'intérieur et des transports
ont prévu de se revoir dans deux jours
afin de refaire un point
quant aux ressortissants russes
encore présents sur le sol chinois la
porte parole de la diplomatie russe a
dressé un tout dernier bilan
l'ambassade et les consulats généraux de
russie en chine suivent de près la
situation et sont en contact avec nos
compatriotes
il continue les travaux visant à
déterminer le nombre de citoyens russes
qui se trouvent dans les zones de
propagation de la maladie au 30 janvier
aucun cas d'infection pour ce
coronavirus n'a été signalé chez les
citoyens russes se trouvant sur le
territoire chinois
le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères fournit toute l'assistance
possible aux autorité exécutive fédérale
compétente dans leurs contacts avec les
autorités chinoises dans le cadre de
leur réaction risque lié à la
propagation du coronavirus la russie
compte plus de 4000 kilomètres de
frontière terrestre avec la chine
et c'est un report accueille chaque jour
des dizaines de vols en provenance de
villes chinoises
les autorités russes suivent donc de
très près l'évolution de la situation
sur place
face à cette épidémie la communauté
internationale se pose la question de
l'organisation du rapatriement de ses
ressortissants présents en chine de
nombreux ministres ont pris la parole
aujourd'hui à ce propos vous devez avoir
vu notre demande d'affréter deux avions
en chine pour ramener les ressortissants
indiens qui sont dans la province du
hubei une demande officielle a été faite
nous attendons maintenant l'approbation
officielle de la partie chinoise avant
de pouvoir entamer le processus et nous
espérons que cette approbation sera
bientôt donnée concernant le cas du
nouveau virus en chine
il n'est pas nécessaire d'interrompre
les vols en provenance de chine car cela
ne fera qu'affaiblir l'économie
cambodgienne et dégrader les relations
entre le cambodge et la chine
il n'est pas nécessaire d'évacuer les
étudiants cambodgiens
les ambassadeurs et les employés
consulaires d'autres régions de chine
vers le cambodge
aujourd'hui de son citoyen japonais ro
viendront de wuhan nous continuons de
travailler pour faire en sorte que
toutes les personnes restantes ne rentre
chez elle et continuerons de faire tous
les efforts pour gérer la santé des
rapatriés en fin de compte notre
gouvernement fera ce qui est dans le
meilleur intérêt de l'australie et des
australiens
c'est ce que nous faisons ici nous avons
des australiens en détresse nous
proposons de les faire sortir de cette
partie de la chine et de les ramener
chez eux mais nous voulons nous assurer
qu'ils traversent la période d'isolement
et je pense que les mesures que nous
avons prises sont appropriés dans
l'intérêt de notre pays
en images sur les moments clés de cette
épidémie sur le territoire français
[Musique]
me
où
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]
où
et pour le docteur gerald de 15 avec
médecin urgentiste l hôtel-dieu ap-hp
la priorité est de définir la virulence
du virus pour déterminer la stratégie à
adopter
la vraie question c'est quelle est la
virulence quelle est la gravité de ce
virus est ce que ce virus c'est une
grippe
un peu compliqué et ça donne des
pneumonies mais globalement c'est pas
très grave et ça touche des gens qui
sont fragilisés le premier patient qui
est décidée en chine par exemple avait
déjà une tuberculose plus une
une inflexion du myocarde donc on voit
bien que ça a été un peu la goutte d'eau
qui a fait déborder le vase mais le
coronavirus on lui même n'a pas été
responsable de ce décès donc soit c'est
un virus qui est pas plus virulent que
ça il va falloir redescendre d'un cran
en termes de communication parce que
nous aux urgences par exemple ou dans
les services hospitaliers ça va être
impossible de mettre tout le monde en
isolant soi il est très virulent et ça
voudrait dire que la chine peut être
nous cache un certain nombre de choses
ou que les chiffres ne sont pas les bons
chiffres et à ce moment là s'il est très
virulent c'est au moindre contact avec
des gens qui n'ont pas d'antécédents
médicaux
il ya un risque et une gravité ça veut
dire que là effectivement on a raison de
prendre toutes les précautions mais ça
m'a posé problème parce qu'il faudra
avant le nombre de services de
réanimation qui permettront d'accueillir
les malades potentiels
c'est une où c'est une enquête a classé
sans suite désormais le parquet de
vienne s'est prononcé aujourd'hui en
cause la procédure ouverte pour
provocation à la haine à l'encontre
d'une jeune lyonnaise levante le 18
juillet mais il a 16 ans est prise à
partie sur instagram après avoir tenu
des propos insultants envers l'islam
l'enquète se poursuit contre les menaces
de mort et de viol émises à son encontre
ministre de la justice s'est exprimée
hier à ce sujet selon nicole belloubet
je suis ton peut critiquer les religions
par inciter à la haine ministre a depuis
admis une maladresse dans ses propos qui
n'ont pas manqué de faire réagir
qu'est ce qui a pu se passer dans notre
pays pour qu'une ministre de la
république puisse dire que l'insultent à
l'encontre d'une religion est une
atteinte grave à la liberté de
conscience
on s'apprête à rétablir un très peu
laïque droit au blasphème b loubet parle
comme elle agit tout faux même les
religieux du concordat en alsace moselle
ont demandé l'abolition de la répression
du blasphème
bigot
ries et autoritarisme marchent ensemble
stupéfiants belloubet veut interdire le
blasphème dans notre pays
c'est en finir avec la république milla
doit être défendue non poursuivies
belloubet peut-elle encore être ministre
de la république
la question se pose l'outrance et la
vulgarité de ces attaques en ont choqué
plus d'un
mais elle ne justifie en rien les
menaces qui la visent et déshonorent
ceux qui les profèrent milla à 16 ans
elle a toute la vie pour découvrir que
l'islam est peut être autre chose que ce
qu'elles croient mais voyez l'analyse de
ghazi khan n'a ni philosophe et
conférencière franco algérienne mais la
halle incarne une affaire de la société
justement et c'est la république est
menacée
ce sont les valeurs de la république les
lois de la république qui sont menacés
dans la société française aujourd'hui
nous avons des jeunes musulmans qui
considèrent que protéger leur religion
est plus importante que respecter les
lois de la république que nous avons
aujourd'hui en france des non musulmans
qui considèrent que bien là mais la
mérite ce qui lui arrive donc des non
musulmans aussi français qui considèrent
que bafouer la loi de la liberté
d'expression est tout à fait normal je
suppose qu'ils se sont des jeunes de son
âge
donc nous avons aussi un problème c'est
que l'école française ne transmet plus
les valeurs de la république
les valeurs de la modernité les valeurs
de la de l'humanisme et c'est là que se
situe le problème et enfants
cette situation provoque autant de
malaise et de tension car elle révèle
une chose importante le degré de l'
influence du fondamentalisme islamique
au sein de la société française et c'est
la fin de cette édition merci d'avoir
suivi prochain journal demain matin 7
heures du matin heure française
excellente fin de soirée à tous sur arte
france vous avez rendez vous en
attendant avec l'autre match à j moins 3
avant le super bowl grégory petits gens
s'intéressent au foot américain
est-ce du sport de la politique ou du
business
réponse tout de suite
[Musique]
il
quoi pour vous fils république éthique
écoutez c'est une république qui se
préoccupent de lutter contre la
corruption et contre la fraude fiscale
qui a conscience que c'est un enjeu
considérable
le coût de la corruption et est évalué à
pour la france chaque année à 120
milliards le coût de la fraude fiscale
entre 80 et 100 milliards chaque année
évidemment cet argent pourrait être
beaucoup mieux employé de la firme pin
up fillion la classe politique
rappelez-vous étaient sidérés ne
comprenait pas le problème lorsqu'il
faisait tous ça depuis des années chaque
année on nous avons nous découvrons des
pratiques des combines et c'est sans fin
je pense que la population les citoyens
ne réclame pas suffisamment cette
moralisation du citoyen à une doit
reprendre sa place et doit sanctionner
les élus indélicats et doit promouvoir
au contraire ceux qui proposent des
mesures visant à éviter les abus
il semble qu'il existe une architecture
naturel reposant sur le pli quel
avantage la nature aux rétais la
pratique et l'origami et comment
peut-elle produire des schémas de pliage
aussi complexe l'évolution a dû retenir
les systèmes de clips heureux parce que
cela permet de développer de très
grandes surfaces à l'intérieur de tout
petits espaces ce n'est donc pas
surprenant de voir de l'origami dans les
ailes d'insectes et dans les feuilles
dans l'intestin
on peut même voir des système de pliage
semblables sur le cortex les objets
inspirés par les origamis surgissent
déjà dans notre quotidien
comment imaginer que le pliage d'une
simple surfaces planes nous porte vers
la découverte d'un code universel de la
nature
[Musique]
la rivière tout moche et au delà du
cours moyen
et elle s'est inclinée pour saluer le
propriétaire du trouble la tente
traditionnelle et à la demande et fait
cesser cette tempête de neige sinon mon
peuple mourra
[Musique]
chers footballeurs moyens chers
footballeurs américains ou pas le temps
d ouais je suis content j'ai marqué un
super touchdown c'est fini si je vous
dis supporter ou hamburger vous pouvez
me dire soccer mais vous me direz
surtout foot us une religion au pays de
l'oncle sam avec en point d'orgue
comme chaque début février le super bowl
la finale du championnat de nfl le plus
grand show sportif au monde avec cette
année à la mi temps
jennifer lopez et shakira non non non
non le super bowl c'est aussi et surtout
110 millions de téléspectateurs 5,1
millions de dollars pour 30 secondes de
publicité à la télé 1,25 milliard de
chicken wings vendu le super bowl c'est
aussi de la politique contre les tweets
de donald trump et les messages engagés
des sportifs
bref foot us sport politique ou business
on en parle après que général
[Musique]
bienvenue sur rt france pour un nouvel
épisode de l'autre au match consacré
cette semaine aux 54e super bowl
il va avoir lieu ce week-end à miami ce
sera à suivre sur bien sport à partir de
23h30 et aux commentaires il y aura vous
marc angelo soumah bonjour je vous être
consultant dobbin sport mais surtout
ancien joueur de nfl du côté de
cleveland et même ancien président de la
fédération française de foot américain
bonjour et bienvenue à vos côtés à
gérald olivier vous êtes journaliste
franco américain à spécialiste des états
unis de la politique américaine
chercheur associé à l'iris l'institut
prospective sécurité en europe et auteur
du livre à paraître sur la route de la
maison blanche aux éditions jean
picollec bonjour également bienvenus
bonjour messieurs la question qu'on se
pose on l'a entendu dans l'édito c'est
le foot us qu est ce que c est ce que
c'est du sport est ce que c'est de la
politique
est-ce que c'est du business on a posé
cette question à exactement 2007 120
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux sur rt
france et le résultat c'est celui ci 26
% de personnes pensent qu'il s'agit de
sport 69% pensent qu'il s'agit de
business d'économies et cinq pour cent
de politique pour vous marquants du lot
c'est quoi le superbe région ce que vous
auriez même peut-être pu ajouter
est ce qu'il s'agit de religion parce
que quand on est au texas
il ya deux choses qui comptent qui
soutient la vie c'est un l'église de
football américain donc forcément le
football mais qui représente beaucoup
pour eux et la ligue s'est construite
autour bien sûr du sport aussi aux
constructeurs du business c'est à dire
que rapidement on s'est dit il faut que
le sport soit rentable étant donné qu'on
n'est pas dans une économie française où
on est subventionné par l'état
il devait s'en sortir tout seul et donc
forcément le business et la rentabilité
a eu son mot à dire
business is business donc pour vous un
marc angelo et pour vous gérald ou alors
moi j'aurais rajouté un autre terme
c'est du spectacle
j'ai du spectacle c'est un spectacle
basé sur le sport mais c'est d'abord un
spectacle est d'ailleurs les joies de
légende la nfl considère que les matchs
du dimanche ça s'appelle un show donc
c'est vraiment un spectacle et l'idée
c'est un spectacle pour les gens qui
sont dans le stade la très belle image
qui a derrière
oh et puis surtout aujourd'hui un
spectacle télévisé et la réalité du
football américain ce qui est
particulier c'est que c'est un sport
dont les règles semble avoir été écrite
pour la télévision
c'est à dire que vous avez une
succession d'actions qui sont
extrêmement rapides extrêmement
spectaculaire et qui sont interrompus
parce qu'on a plusieurs tentatives on
gagne du terrain progressivement à
chaque interruption
la télévision vous repasse le ralenti de
l'action précédente que vous allez
disséqués c'est un spectacle formidable
et c'est un spectacle qui a conquis
l'amérique au cours des cinquante
soixante dix dernières années et qui est
devenu le premier spectacle télévisuel
aux états unis depuis une bonne
vingtaine d'années
en tous les cas ce spectacle génère
beaucoup d'argent
l'économie du football américain du
super bowl en particulier c'est avec les
mandats coire 5,8 journalistes
accrédités une diffusion dans 180 pays
le super bowl c'est l'événement majeur
de ce début d'année et l'économie qui
l'entourent peut faire perdre la tête
les recettes publicitaires devrait
atteindre les 350 millions de dollars
pour seulement quatre heures d'antenne
sur le terrain une prime de 90 mille
dollars sera attribué pour les
vainqueurs contre 50 milles pour les
perdants côté paris sportifs 5 milliards
de dollars avait été parier illégalement
sur la rencontre de l'an dernier au
total les américains devraient dépenser
près de 15 milliards de dollars dont une
partie non négligeable dans la
nourriture
les fans devraient avaler 1,25 milliard
d'elle de poulet près de 14000 500
tonnes de chips accompagnés de huit
millions de kilos de guacamole de quoi
frôler l'indigestion n'ai pas de
problème pour certains puisque un
américain sur dix n'ira pas travailler
le lendemain
[Musique]
marc angelo on dit souvent que les états
unis si le pays de la démesure quand on
voit ces chiffres c'est le cas ils sont
beaucoup ils sont beaucoup plus nombreux
que nous mais oui il ya des moments où
les américains qui travaillent beaucoup
se disent là on va se lâcher là on va
pouvoir y travailleront pas le lendemain
ce sera l'un des dix acteurs en l'avenir
du super bowl où tout est permis
on peut justement profiter avec ses amis
bien manger et je prends un jour de
repos le lendemain un américain sur dix
ne travaillera pas le lendemain les neuf
autres ils font quoi ils regardent quand
même super bowl la veille contre la fête
c'est un lendemain de fête
le super bowl est programmée un dimanche
et à cause de la télévision il est
programmé de plus en plus tard le
dimanche parce qu'aux états unis vous
avez une fenêtre de télévision qui
s'appelle le prime time qui est celle où
il ya le plus de téléspectateurs et qui
en gros va de 18h à 21h donc on va
programmer le match aussi tard que
possible pour qu'il passe en prime time
et les gens continuent à faire la fête
au delà du match vous avez beaucoup
parlé de chilliwack comolet il ya de la
bière derrière beaucoup beaucoup de
bière donc parle de je crois de 52
millions de packs de bière on ne sait
pas combien il ya de bouteilles ou de
canettes dans les packs de viol aux
états unis mais voilà ça fait quand même
beaucoup
on a on a vu 1 15 milliard de dollars
c'est ce que vont dépenser des
américains en marge du superbowl
ces 15 milliards gérald olivier profite
à qui sait quoi l'économie du vin vous
l'avez vu c'est principalement de la
nourriture des profite aux transports il
profite à l'industrie hôtelière parce
que malgré tout la ville qui est la
ville hôte du super bowl voit une marée
humaine se déverser et pas simplement le
jour du match le super bowl ça dure une
semaine là le match aura lieu dans trois
jours mais ça fait une semaine qu'à
miami c'est la fête tous les soirs que
vous avez des défilés que vous avez des
marques qui sont venus pour faire des
promotions de ce que les joueurs y sont
ni qui sont liés par des contrats mais
aussi des obligations professionnelles
dont vous avez un grand rendez-vous de
business autour du super bowl et le
match c'est en quelque sorte de croix en
hiver c'est le dernier événement d'une
montée en puissance économique qui va
bien au-delà de ce qui se passe sur le
terrain le dimanche soir mais les gens
qui vont qui vont aller au stade pour
voir cette finale entre les
kansas city chiefs et les fortunes
diverses de san francisco ceux qui vont
au stade c'est qui c'est les gens qui
sont fortunés parce que le prix du
billet l'année dernière le prix moyen
c'était 4600 $ ca commence à 3000 ça
peut aller jusqu'à 15000 dollars s
dichotomie entre le rêve américain et le
super bowl c'est le problème qu'ils
avaient en fait c'est que alors cette
année je crois que c'est à cinq ou six
mille dollars la place et en plus y'a le
marché parallèle où ça peut monter
jusqu'à 10,1 en effet elle espère que ça
monte jusqu'à 10000 sur le marché
parallèle mais ça veut dire que dans le
stade mais proposer en parallèle à
moitié
comment ils profitent ou parler du
marché par là-même permettez moi de vous
couper mais il profite à qui ce marché
par à ceux qui peuvent se le permettre
puis à des reventes alain petit peu
compliqué et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'une des critiques qui ai fait la nfl
et au super bowl c'est que l'événement
lui même est devenu un événement de
classe il est réservé aux gens qui
savent s'y prendre aux gens qui ont des
réseaux aux gens qui ont des moyens
parce que là on parle du du billet
d'entrée du ticket d'entrée au passage
si vous achetez si vous n'avez jamais
les yeux ou les mains sur un ticket de
super bowl il n'y a pas le prix du
ticket parce qu'en fait il n'y a pas de
prix le prix c'est ce que vous êtes
prêts à payer pour rentrer sur le stade
et si vous l'achetez de manière
officielle vous n'allez pas acheter le
billet vous allez acheter un package
vous allez acheter à un hôtel de luxe
vous allez acheter telle visite
on vous fera ça à 15 20 à 25 mille
dollars donc c'était tout un événement
les plus malins sont ceux qui
parviennent à acheter des tickets et les
revendre au marché parallèle jamais les
joueurs qui font sens et comment comment
il le vit ça vous parliez tout à l'heure
du texas le texan moyens comment est-ce
qui vise à ce qui va forcément fortunés
voilà une double participation au super
bowl est assez bien sûr dont on vient de
parler qui rentre au stade mais aussi
tout ce que la nfl a créé autour de
l'événement et vous parlez de la semaine
la semaine est jonché d'événements pour
tous les fans où les fans peuvent y
aller avec un droit d'entrée bien
entendu mais beaucoup moins que l'entrée
au super bowl ce qui fait que en fait ce
que vous allez faire c'est passé une
semaine à miami rencontrer des joueurs
de toutes les équipes qui vont passer
des événements des rencontres avec
l'équipe qui participent au super bowl
tout type d'événement pour les plantes
pour les grands et pour les petits et
ensuite vous allez regarder le superbowl
ce qui fait que
la participation au super bowl c'est pas
juste regarder le match s'est passé six
semaines
et participez à la mi temps cette année
il va y avoir des différends lopez chez
qui règne l'année dernière il y avait
lady gaga ça aussi c'est un véritable
show il ya beaucoup de gens surtout dans
le monde qui regarde même pas le super
bowl qui regarde juste le show à la mi
temps et qui ensuite est un atelier ou
font autre chose et ça fait partie de la
construction de l'expérience nfl vous
allez à une quand vous allez voir un
match
vous allez vivre une expérience qui
n'est pas juste le match de football n'a
qu'un qui est la manière dont reçoit des
animations autour pour vos enfants pour
vous le spectacle à la mi-temps le fait
que vous mangez bien tout cela ça fait
partie de l'expérience nfl et on veut en
faire profiter un maximum de monde on ne
dise pas juste ceux qui aiment le
football américain ou bizet la famille
on vise 300 à metz pour toucher le plus
de monde possible évidemment et faire le
plus d'argent gérald olivier oui oui en
propre à la télévision tout à l'heure je
vous disais que c'est du spectacle
d'abord le half time shoah le show de la
mi temps il a été inventé
parce qu'au début les premiers super
bowl n'y avait pas de show à la mi temps
mais il a été inventé par les chaînes de
télévision pour conserver l'audience
entre les deux mi temps c'est le
football c'est quatre quarts temps mais
en fait ces deux mi temps parce qu'on
joue deux quart temps puis après on fait
une pause et puis on reprend pour les
deux derniers quarts temps mais à la mi
temps vous avez du point de vue des
chaînes de télévision le risque que le
chanteur allait se coucher il est tard
il est il est tard sur la côte est et on
travaille parfois le lendemain et donc
il fallait garder le spectacle les
téléspectateurs devant l'écran